testing testing I guess everything works
this is your one minute warning our
meeting will start in one minute
that's that's
okay good morning everyone and welcome
to the
January what is today the 17th Tuesday
the 17th of January 2023 welcome to
science technology and energy
I'll go over our agenda in just a minute
but first I'd ask you all to rise and
join representative Noel who will lead
us in the Pledge of Allegiance
okay thank you and uh as I mentioned
earlier we have a full agenda today
throughout the afternoon
we're going to start with a presentation
by the Department of Environmental
Services between now and roughly noon
whenever they get done
and then we'll break for lunch
after that we'll come back at 1 pm for a
presentation by The Joint utilities
that's eversource Liberty and Unitil
and that will be followed at 3 pm by a
presentation by the New Hampshire
Electric Co-op
and I'll just remind members of the
committee that we will also be meeting
on January 19th which is Thursday
however there's a little bit of a
wrinkle there
last Wednesday the government relations
officer for ISO New England who is our
first presenter of the day
contracted covid
and as of
Sunday he was still testing positive
so unless he gets a negative test today
we probably will have to postpone our
ISO New England presentation on Thursday
and since there's only one other
presentation that day which is the New
England power generators Association
we're probably postpone both of those
presentations till later on
that's going to be problematic because
on Monday January 23rd
puc is coming in in the morning but then
we're going to have Bill hearings in the
afternoon
and then on Tuesday January 24th
the Community power Coalition of New
Hampshire is coming in for a
presentation first thing in the morning
but then we're having Bill hearings
later in the day and we're even having
an exec session
that afternoon
so
rescheduling the iso New England and New
England power generators uh
presentations is going to be problematic
because we've already mapped out a bill
schedule the bill hearing schedule
that is pretty full for the month of
February so we'll have to see what
happens
with that said I'd like to welcome now
the Department of Environmental Services
and ask them to present to the committee
and say good morning to commissioner
Robert Scott good morning
good morning Mr chair and members of the
the committee uh thanks for having us uh
as I'm sure you're aware most of the
presentation today will be from the air
Resources Division but I I wanted to
basically make a cameo and I brought
some of our department leadership just
if nothing else so you could see their
face uh and I wanted to make myself
available for questions any questions
also so again uh for the record my name
is Bob Scott I'm commissioner for the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services I've been in
state government for 26 years so I've uh
you know as Mark and I joke behind me I
can't keep a job so I've had many jobs
within state government but my current
one is this commissioner here at one
point I was a division director as
director Wright has so he can blame me
for any any any uh past issues with with
the the division so uh with that if I
could I'd like to behind me I have our
assistant uh commissioner uh Mark
Sanborn
good morning everyone
and uh our Waste Management director uh
Mike wimsat
as well as our Water Division uh
director Rainey Pelletier
so so uh quickly so for the Department
just to give you an idea obviously their
resource division is is an important
part of what we do uh of late some of
our our
things that have been taking a lot of
our time are we have large amounts of
infrastructure money for water and
wastewater between arpa
we received 185 million of State the
state portion of that for water
Wastewater and Dam infrastructure uh the
infrastructure act the the bill act is
moving a lot of money in the next five
years for water and wastewater uh
infrastructure we're kind of picking
apart now the uh Ira the inflation
reduction act to see if there's any uh
venues there but I don't I don't think
for water infrastructure uh necessarily
so that's taking up a lot of our time
also
um water contamination uh in emerging
contaminants is this as science improves
and we're able to measure things we're
finding more things so that's those two
things are probably taking up the
majority of my time uh just for general
interest uh I also I mentioned I have
worn a lot of hats in the past the other
hat I wear is I'm the governor's cyber
security advisor for critical
infrastructure so I spend a fair amount
of time on that that work also
so with that if there's any questions if
not I'll
I'm certainly happy to answer any
questions I'll
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh since you mentioned Water
and Wastewater and since um we know that
throughout the state our
Water Systems particularly this the
sewer systems are woefully Antiquated uh
what what programs are like like the top
three programs that that would that
would be useful useful for the monies
that we you know just
just received what do they plan for that
sure so we have multiple pots of money
for uh water uh drinking water and clean
water which is Wastewater we have the
state revolving Loan Fund program which
has been long-standing uh that's being
plused up significantly with the
infrastructure bill so that'll be the
venue for most of the funds for what's
called disadvantaged communities
which we have a definition of uh which
is basically primarily based on medium
household income but also if you have a
lot of water contamination those systems
can can qualify for up to 50 loan
forgiveness so that's our primary with
the 185 million I mentioned in arpa
those are all grants most of those have
been already offered we we did multiple
programs with with that for both Water
and Wastewater including planning Asset
Management uh and then just just plain
infrastructure uh jobs jobs gives me
projects where we took took the srf
applications and we match them and
basically we were in a mode which is
very nice to be is
we did offer letters to the community
saying
uh congratulations you applied for x
amount of money for infrastructure loans
we've got to give you slightly less
because we're giving you that much in
Grants and now the rest is in in loans
so we're at that mode now for arpa we
have a little bit left but but not not
much
we also have for drinking water systems
not Wastewater systems we have the the
groundwater drink the drinking water
groundwater trust fund uh in that on a
yearly bet and I'm on the commission for
that
um one of the the Commissioners for that
uh we
on an annual basis we typically give up
between 20 and 25 million dollars uh for
drinking water projects a combination of
loan and grants also so those are some
of our primary uh pro programs if you
have a constituent that's interested
certainly they can call me but uh if you
go to our website we have a very good
website that articulates all of that and
and directs you where to go to to find
those things so I would recommend just
Googling Des infrastructure and you'll
find that website
foreign
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question as well thank you very much Mr
chair and thank you for being here
um you've talked about air and water can
you tell me what division soil comes
under
uh
sorry for the speakers right between the
representative and myself uh
so if it if it's soils management like
uh biosolids that type of thing it's in
the Water Division
I'm taking more of soil contamination uh
then it'd be the waste management
division okay thank you
okay seeing no further questions you can
move right along thank you
uh thank you Mr chair
members of the committee uh my name is
Craig Wright I serve as the air
Resources Division director
uh we did plan today to have Mike
Fitzgerald here as well he's a very
frequent flyer before this committee
he unfortunately fell ill this weekend
and can't join us but I do want to
introduce a couple of my staff that are
here to my right is Becky ohler she's
the administrator of our Technical
Services Bureau
behind me on this side is Joe Fontaine
and also Phil lamoreaux who is
relatively new to the division but a a
rising up-and-comer in the division so
so we handed out uh our first
presentation today you should all have
that we're also going to do a Reggie
presentation and when I'm done so I'll
tell uh I think we'll take less than an
hour and now we'll leave plenty of time
for questions that's that's the fun part
in my opinion anyway so
laughs
let's make sure that advances so the air
Resources Division consists of three
bureaus I'm not going to walk through
these bureaus because my latest slides
I'll hit on some of the responsibilities
for each one of those bureaus but also
we have a director's office that's
obviously for division oversight
budgeting management policy decisions
those types of things but we also have a
technical group in the year in the uh
director's office and that's our
atmospheric sciences unit that was
formerly had by Dr Jeff Underhill but he
recently retired
mm-hmm
so here's just a list of our senior
staff including myself and Mike
Fitzgerald's phone numbers feel free to
reach out to any one of these folks
anytime you have a question but always
the buck stops with Mike and I so feel
free to reach to us first if you feel so
inclined we have a pretty
pretty well
seasoned staff for managing the division
I did mention Dr Underhill he retired he
that's the vacancy listed there in the
atmospheric science unit
foreign
one slide too far
three four
so in addition to implementing state
laws the air Resources Division is uh
implements the vast majority of the
federal Clean Air Act a lot what of what
we do comes out of the Clean Air Act
uh some of those major things are
monitoring air quality across the state
to ensure compliance with the federal
air quality standards which sets a Level
Playing Field across the country EPA
establishes the standards but it's up to
states to measure and monitor and make
sure that we maintain the standards
in terms of those standards we have to
develop and Implement enforce and
control strategies to meet the federal
air quality standards we issue all Air
permits in New Hampshire whether it's a
state permit or a federal permit under
the Clean Air Act we're a fully
delegated state so permanent sources can
deal directly with Des for all Air
permits they don't have to go to EPA
part of our role is obviously getting
out in the field doing compliance
inspections uh complaint investigations
and enforcement actions enforcements not
our preferred course of action we prefer
everybody to be in compliance but we
will we have tools that we do use and we
work through the Des legal office and
also on occasion with the attorney
general's office
terms of Staffing we have 65 full-time
positions currently nine of them are
vacant that's about a 14 vacancy rate
um I think that's pretty consistent
across state government 15 to 20 percent
I think is the number I usually hear
terms of the type of Staff we have we
have a lot of Engineers uh mechanical
chemical civil engineers environmental
and life science Majors atmospheric
science Health Sciences and we have a
couple attorneys they're not in legal
positions but they are attorneys
um one thing I did want to know one of
the challenges we're facing as a
Division I think this is also across
state government is I'm looking at
probably nine senior staff retiring in
the next couple of years
all told that it's about 225 years of
State service and when I was thinking
about this morning I think there's
actually a tenth one I could add on to
that so
um in terms of trying to address that
we've been working on updating a lot of
our policies and procedures make sure we
have good standard operating procedures
in place and we're also really out there
trying to attract some good young Talent
like Phil back here so uh those people
are the future of the division so
in terms of where do we get our
operating Revenue this chart goes back
to FY 10 so this is a 12 years of
operating data and you'll see all toll
we really haven't risen that much in
terms of 12 years we've gone from about
seven million dollars in Revenue to just
a little over eight million dollars
um that will that last bar is a little
bit higher than normal because some of
that deals with the timing of federal
money so you can see we're very reliant
on permit fees uh permit fees in fact
support two of our three bureaus
supports the permitting group and also
our compliance and enforcement Bureau
that's generally close to half of our
operating Revenue uh we also receive a
significant portion about somewhere
between 25 and 30 percent depending on
the year federal funds uh Motor Vehicles
the largest source of air pollution in
the state contribute a small amount to
our operating budget and then there's a
little bit of general fund money we get
and I'll I'll hit some of those general
fund programs later on
always like to point out that
maintaining good air quality is
important not only for the environment
but also the economy one of the things
we used to struggle with not so much now
was we did not meet certain federal air
quality standards therefore we need to
develop more and more stringent
regulations we've we are currently
attainment for all of the national
ambient air quality standards that's a
good thing now our goal is to maintain
and don't put us back into
non-attainment Obviously good air
quality protects public health and
decreases health care costs we know New
Hampshire is a beautiful state people
love to come here to see our mountains
swim in our Lakes air quality is
important not only for visibility but
people love to hike our mountains and
some of the worst air quality we have
sometimes on top of Mount Washington
believe it or not so
um and it also it really helps good air
also helps to maintain the health of our
forests and our forests help maintain
the quality of our water so it's all
interrelated in my mind so we they're
all important component to maintaining a
healthy state
I mentioned the federal Clean Air Act
Amendments of 1990
the act establishes that EPA established
the national ambient air quality
standards for six pollutants ozone
sulfur dioxide and nitrogen oxide
particulate matter lead and Co
historically ozone sulfur dioxide and
um
in particular matter have been our
biggest challenges the Clean Air Act
also establishes a program called
hazardous air pollutants it regulates
toxics including Mercury the state of
New Hampshire does also have a state air
toxics program the federal program is a
technology-based program where it
requires certain levels of controls
based on the size of your Source the
stadia toxics program is a health-based
program where we have ambient air
quality standard limits for I think over
600 air pollutants so
um EPA does review the national ambient
air quality standards every five years
they're supposed to under the yak
sometimes they're a little bit late on
that and you'll see a couple charts
later on where EPA has made changes to
the air quality standards and I can tell
you they generally always go down as
science gets better and we have a better
understanding as to how air pollution
impacts human health
I kind of already mentioned this but one
of the key components of the ACT is if
you don't meet the federal air quality
standards you get into what's known as
non-attainment that's not good for us as
a state from a health standpoint or from
a standpoint of having to develop
regulations
um some of the programs that are are
required under the federal program are
the new source review program this is
for new major sources or modifications
to existing major sources emissions
offsets for certain categories in
certain areas
um if if we're in non-attainment Motor
Vehicle Inspection Transportation
Conformity those those are all things
that we didn't invent they all come out
of the federal Clean Air Act and there
is what's known as a savings clause and
the Clean Air Act Like I said even
though we are in attainment with all the
federal standards it doesn't mean we get
to take the foot off the gas pedal we
need to maintain our attainment status
and we can't backslide so that's an
important part of the ACT
hmm
I mentioned one of our one of our
fundamental things that we're required
to do Under the ACT is to monitor air
quality across the state we have a fully
approved uh annual ambient air
monitoring plan this is a map of where
we have our monitors we literally Mount
we monitor from the top of Mount
Washington to the base of Mount
Washington down the Connecticut River
Valley across the Southern Tier of the
Seacoast and up the almost up the
Merrimack River Valley and across in
Laconia now we don't monitor for all
pollutants at all of these stations we
some of them are single pollutant
monitoring sites such as Pembroke we
only think we monitor to there is sulfur
dioxide and that's downwind of the ball
power plant so it makes sense to have a
monitor there
um
Mount Washington we traditionally Mark
to Ozone up there we are now also
monitoring Trace Co we do occasionally
have stratospheric ozone intrusions not
man-made events up there so that Co
monitor will help us
so here's a here's a picture of a three
of our monitoring sites in Londonderry
Portsmouth and Miller State Park Miller
State Park is a high level site similar
to Mount Washington
these sites are we generally construct
these sites ourselves and put the
equipment in them we um each one of
these sites probably has somewhere from
150 to half a million dollars worth of
equipment that we need to maintain in
accordance with Federal uh monitoring
requirements
people often ask me how is the air
quality in New Hampshire I've been doing
this for 36 years and I can tell you
that the air quality today is a lot
better than when I started in 1988 a lot
of that is a result of the fine work of
the Clean Air Act which is uh some of
the largest Federal Environmental
legislation and I in my opinion has been
very successful
it's also the result of some statutes
that we've passed right here in some
cases New Hampshire has led the way for
example
the 1990 amendments had a federal acid
rain program New Hampshire had a state
asset rain program prior to the federal
program so sometimes we lead the way
in terms of General air quality these
charts represent the last two or three
years worth of data and it measures
percent to days the green bar means good
the yellow bar means moderate and
there's a little tiny bar at the top
that says USG that's unhealthy for
sensitive groups
did I see a hand up or
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you very much this is
regarding the um the air monitoring
stations can you tell me if any of them
specifically measure for pfas in the air
I'm sorry measures what
no
okay I don't they're they're the ability
to measure uh pfas and ambient air is a
significant challenge
uh we have measured pfast like out of
Saint Cobain's emission Stacks
um that's a very uh technical uh test
method it's it's it's set up by EPA but
there's nothing right now for ambient
thank you
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman um could you
advance your slide to be the one you
were talking about
is the the green bars and the Red Bar
yeah uh this slide and the next one and
what you were just talking about is a
wonderful to see
um but New Hampshire of course is
a relatively small state correct not an
island and we are famously downwind of
the rest of the country as the
person in charge of air quality in New
Hampshire Do you have a
is there like a fraction in your mind
uh
the extent to which
this these great results are the result
of New Hampshire policies
versus policies that have been
implemented
throughout the rest of the country and
in other states by virtue of the Clean
Air Act so I would I would say it's a
combination of course it's a combination
I'm asking um I would say
as a downwind state we have benefited
significantly from the reduction of air
pollution from upwind States there's
absolutely no doubt about it
uh Dr Underhill used to tell me that on
a poor air quality day sometimes
probably 90 percent plus percent of that
pollution came into New Hampshire so it
was probably already above the standards
before it got here we add an incremental
amount to that
um that's on a general wide scale basis
now there are certainly cases for
example you could be downwind of a
particular source and that particular
Source could certainly add a significant
portion of what you're breathing locally
so does that answer your question
absolutely thank you
representative Summers has a question
and I'd remind the members to turn their
microphones off when they're finished
speaking thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh just a quick
question looking at this
um comparison direct comparison how does
the air quality in New Hampshire compare
to uh directly compared to other states
outside of New England
generally
um I would say Maine New Hampshire and
Vermont probably have fairly similar
levels of air pollution on most days
uh there are some localized situations
again uh primarily with like wood smoke
in the winter time
uh the worst air quality in New England
is in the Connecticut region uh they're
they're right downwind of New York City
the I-95 Corridor uh they continue to
struggle with ozone and they continue to
not meet the federal air quality
standards in Connecticut and New York
I guess my question was sorry is how
does it compare to States outside of New
England oh sorry misunderstood that
um it varies across the country there
there are local situations that occur
um I would say our air has cleaned up
quite a bit
um historically ozone has been our
biggest pollutant of concern
um I would say as the tailpipe of the
city for some pollutants on some days
we're worse than other parts of the
countries but I would say most of the
time we're as good if not better
so there's no ranking system of States
plane versus Georgia representative
Summers let me interrupt you for a
second
I'd remind members that if you have a
follow-up question you have to ask
permission to the chair to ask that
question
go ahead if you have a follow-up
quick follow-up there is repeating the
questions sorry is uh
um how does there's no ranking system or
anything we don't have a ranking system
EPA doesn't have a ranking system I'm
aware of the American Lung Association
does put out an annual report and they
they rate all countries all counties in
the country
um that report usually comes out I think
in the early summer time
historically we've gotten
better and better grades we have on
occasion gotten C's D's and even an F
once in a while
primarily due to Ozone at some of our
higher elevations
they have a very stringent ranking
system in my opinion though
representative lewicki has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions one issue I wonder
about is whether there are Corrections
for local sources you know very local
sources at the monitoring stations I'm
pretty sure there's a large propane tank
at the top of an ad knock and also I
think there's a diesel generator and if
those are putting out uh you know
running locally they could screw up your
readings yeah we um we actually try very
hard we have a incredibly skilled air
monitoring staff
um very seasoned we work closely with
EPA in setting up our monitoring sites
but one of the things we certainly try
to do is we want them to be
representative of the general air
quality in that region
so you would try to locate your your
monitors in in a way such that they
would not be impacted directly by local
local sources like you're describing
representative Christian has a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um another question related to the
citing of the air quality measurements
I'm noticing there's two rather close
together in Portsmouth and in Rye but
none where I am in Manchester how do you
sure I'd wear just like them and um yep
that's a great that's a great question
and actually there's a reason we have
two so close to each other
um in Portsmouth and Rye one of the
things we've known about ozone pollution
in the summertime is it can penetrate
either right at the coast or it can
penetrate father Inland depending on
local weather conditions and whether you
have a Sea Breeze or not
so the one we have a little bit further
out at
Odeon point is very representative of
the of the ocean land interface so we
purposely put the one further Inland to
as a scientific uh monitor to see if in
fact the ozone is penetrating that far
inland so
um in terms of there are certain
criteria under the federal Clean Air Act
that determines how many monitors a
state needs generally it's a
population-based formula and we stick
consistent with what EPA requires
foreign
representative Noel
thank you chair uh
I'm from Berlin and I grew up with the
mill oh yes and I worked at the Mill and
I know that they did a lot of air
testing uh do we have access to that
information and could we make a
comparison to current air standards in
Berlin
um we I we don't currently have a
monitor in Berlin historically we did
have monitors up there
[Music]
um
primarily around the paper mill as
you're describing because obviously that
was a very significant Source
um I believe we used to monitor for
sulfur Co and maybe some particular
matter
um given the current situation up in
Berlin we don't think that there's a
need to have a site-specific monitor
there so
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for giving me a question one really
quick question since it's in my area
sure can you tell me what pollutants
does the does the site in Londonderry
measure Londonderry is actually what we
call an encore site it's a very
specialized site New Hampshire has two
Encore sites I believe we're monitoring
ozone there we also have a GC there and
we monitor a number of volatile organic
compounds I think we have a trace sulfur
dioxide monitor there I think
so
it's one of our most advanced most
recent sites thank you
and I could certainly Supply the
committee with a map that not only shows
where the monitors are but what is being
monitored for at that particular site if
Joe can make a note of that
that would be useful we appreciate that
we can do that representative
has a question
thank you chair if you could ask uh Mr
Wright he mentioned a GC if you could
explain it to the committee so a GC is a
gas chromatograph it's a highly
sensitive scientific instrument that can
actually
speciate various types of volatile
organic compounds like it could measure
Benzene it can measure toluene there's a
whole list of air toxics that we monitor
at that site as part of the national
ozone program
uh those are all precursors to Ozone so
that's why those scientific sites were
developed
New Hampshire is one of the few states
in the country that has two Encore sites
we have one
there in Londonderry and also the one at
the top of Pacman that knock is an
encore site as well and the reason that
one was chosen is because it's it's a
high level so it's an indicate of what's
transported into the state
you need a follow-up
just going to say thank you okay all
right representative McWilliams is
recognized for a question thank you
chair bows
um I I do want to ask a follow-up
question I checked out the American Lung
Association ranking for the counties in
New Hampshire
and so I'm seeing that we're doing
pretty good except for Rockingham which
has a c everybody else's A's and B's we
don't appear to have any data for
Carroll County Stratford County or
Sullivan County and so my question is
what do we need to do in order to get
some data for those counties if you're
well if you're in if we were really
wanted to do that we would need to
establish new sites
um what's that follow -up question
follow up what does that entail to
establish a new site well one if we we
would need to work it into our annual uh
monitoring Network plan that gets
reviewed by EPA to ensure that we're
meeting the federal requirements
the biggest thing biggest hurdle would
probably be one finding a site which we
can do uh two would be equipping the
site and determining what you wanted to
monitor for I mean we are setting up a
new site in Laconia we're moving we're
at currently at with the old state
school is in Laconia we're going to move
to a more of a downtown location
um that's going to cost us at a minimum
150 000 dollars
so to establish a new site you're
probably looking at someone like 150 to
500 000 depending on what you want to
monitor for okay thank you
representative berezny has a question
well you guys have been saving them up
thank you thank you chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh so
building on the previous uh question
what
um of the revenue chart how much of that
um is tied to spending any particular
spending for example with building a new
testing site does that come from the
um the federal funds or is it is this
like a general fund for the Department
that then pays for different things so
the way we've built and monitored built
these sites up over the years is largely
with the federal federal funds we get
it's a requirement
um we generally get about 1.7 million
dollars from EPA annually and I would
estimate we probably spend somewhere
750 000 to a million dollars a year on
maintaining the sites uh that's involves
buying new equipment and the staff
necessary to go out to the sites we've
done a really good job at automating
sites but we still need to do field
visits and we still need to have field
technicians
so EPA Logic the only the the way the
state is kicked in historically on our
ad monitoring sites is every two years
we do tend to put in a we do put in a
capital budget request offer some
equipment we've been fairly successful I
think the last three capital budgets and
we usually get somewhere in the
neighborhood of two to three hundred
thousand dollars which that goes
strictly to buying new equipment some of
our equipment is quite old
thank you
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
director Craig
um so to follow on with my colleagues
question
um on the revenue piece if you were to
add additional monitoring stations for
the Three Counties that representative
McWilliams referenced
would be nice to have some information
there how would that affect the budget
and would you would you be able to to do
that within the constraints of the
federal monies that you received today
not right now yeah it would not be
possible
um to I don't think it would be possible
to establish three new sites under our
existing federal funds okay thank you
foreign we've exhausted our questions
for now continue all right we'll get
we'll get back to the Chart we were on
just general air quality
um this is our 10 counties and the far
right side is high elevations again
that's Mount Washington and uh Pacman
dad knock sites the good news is
generally 90 of the days we have good
air quality in New Hampshire about 10
percent of the days we have moderate air
pollution and then a handful of days
when I was here when I started
36 years ago it wouldn't be unusual to
have 10 15 25 days a year primarily in
the summer with ozone exceedances today
we probably have we average Maybe
three to five exceedances a year we're
not in violation the way the math works
but in those days we try to predict
those days and we do put out what we
call air quality action days and the
other thing I'll just note about our
monitoring site if you go to the Des
website I should have put this in the
slides we have we have almost up-to-date
current data on our Des website of
current air quality it's about it's
about an hour old so it updates every
hour so
so uh this is a great chart I'll just
note uh that I started in 1988 so I'm
going to claim that this is all Craig
Wright uh no just kidding of course uh
realistically uh this chart I think
really portrays what it the success of
the Clean Air Act in New Hampshire the
success of our own State legislation you
can see here from 1990 sulfur dioxide
emissions are down 90 percent in the
state that's largely because we've
switched away from coal as our main
power source and switching to Natural
Gas
Co is down about 80 percent that's
largely because of improvements in
Transportation uh the the Berlin site
was historically a very large Co Source
but that is now gone as well Knox is
down 75 that's important nitrogen oxide
because that's a precursor to Ozone
that's one of those pollutants we need
to control to keep our ozone under
control plus there are health-based
standards for Knox itself vocs volatile
organic compounds down 70 percent PM 2.5
down 50 percent uh you can see some some
some years there's major drops some
years it's more of a gradual drop but
this is a good long-term trend for New
Hampshire and we'll be updating this for
with 2022 data um shortly so
now I'm just going to hit some
highlights for our three bureaus our
first Bureau is our permitting
environmental health Bureau this is REI
permitting program in New Hampshire we
have 805 permanent facilities in New
Hampshire 28 of them are what we call
Title V sources so those are major
federal sources that require state
permits we have 264 temporary and state
operating permits those are sources at
New Hampshire has decided and we've put
into our federal plan that we were going
to permit that level of source so I
would call them significant State
sources and then we have 422 General
permits and 91 permit by notifications
the only reason I mention them is
because those are fully online
registration processes it's something
we've been really trying to do is get
all of our permits up online we're going
to continue to work on that so in the
near future and this is just some
statistics there I think you can see if
you look at the numbers we generally
what comes in goes out we've run a very
efficient permit program we get very few
complaints from our permanent sources
about timeliness which I think is good
means we're doing our job if you see a
number that's higher than the number
received that simply because there may
have been an application that came in
late the last year so generally we do a
pretty good job of getting permits in
and out
our environmental health program is
within the permitting Environmental
Health Group this is a
staff of I think five or six folks they
not only serve the air Resources
Division they also serve other divisions
as well they work closely with the waste
management program and the Water
Division as well in that program we run
well we what we call an atsdr it's a
long long name there you can read that
for yourself but that was a grant that
we had had for 20 years and we lost it
in 2017 that provides but we did get it
back three years ago so that current
founding cycle ends in March of 2023 and
we just put in an application for a new
five-year Grant this program not only
serves the other divisions and the air
divisions with environmental health
questions but it also does a great deal
of community outreach in areas where
there is environmental contamination
they help with risk management they help
with communication about environmental
risk so it's a great it's a great
program very pleased to have it in the
air division
um also Senate Bill 309 a couple years
ago I don't remember what year created a
health risk assessor and a toxicologist
position and that continues to support
pfas standards and risk assessments
those are both generally funded
positions I also like to point out that
we as an agency help other other
entities such as Dartmouth and unh
get grants we provide technical
assistance to those folks on grant
opportunities and we partner with them
we don't get no money from them
generally it's just an in-kind service
that we're providing under the general
funds but we've been able they've been
able to leverage almost three quarters
of a million dollars for various studies
related to pfas so we're pleased to
continue that we've also been developing
some education tools for local community
leaders related to contamination cancer
investigations and we also partner very
heavily with dphs Department of Public
Health Services they also have an
environmental health tracking program so
we spend a lot of time working with
those folks
mm-hmm
our compliance Bureau
um this does exactly what you would
think it goes out in the field does
compliance inspections you can see some
of the statistics there 57 inspections
uh one of our goals is again we're a
fully delegated State
um we have we have a department
enforcement policy but we also have a
federal enforcement policy that we need
to follow it's our goal to handle
enforcement actions in the state when
and where necessary rather than have EPA
come into the state we think that's we
can manage it I think you see down there
before last year we had 38 enforcement
actions with no federal over filing so
we would consider that to be a
successful program
we also do stack testing there's a
picture I think on the right bottom here
um that's one of my guys actually
climbing a stack uh they do literally go
up on the stack uh sometimes a couple
hundred feet above the ground
um so not a job for the uh for the not
the strong-hearted so
um we also have an admissions inventory
program we've been working hard we have
to report certain emissions data and
compliance data up to EPA and in 2001 we
got a Federal grant to help bring our
admissions inventory database make it
more automated to feed information to
EPA rather than somebody literally
having to type into the federal system
we get it into our system and we
periodically upload to them and we also
got a grant last year for us to create
an online emissions reporting portal so
this would be industry being able to
report information directly into the
data system so I think we have a
question representative munz has a
question sure thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question of the
permitted facilities that we have in New
Hampshire how frequently does an
inspector get to the to each of those so
I mentioned that we have different
categories of sources we have the title
V sources which are the major sources we
generally have to be there at least once
every two years under the federal
program
all the other state sources under the
federal guidance we have to be there at
least once every five years that's boots
on the ground we do on occasion they
obviously need to file reports and
records with us so that is reviewed
whenever those reports and Records come
in some people report
quarterly some people report annually
but we are we are checking in between
the inspections and the other thing is
if we get a complaint against somebody
we generally go out and try to put boots
on the ground to follow up on complaints
foreign
asbestos management the there is an
asbestos program in the air division
it's primarily focused on folks who do
demo and renovation work whether it's
asbestos we have we have there's a
federal program nishap that New
Hampshire's delegated to do we also have
a federal what they call a hero program
which is asbestos in schools they give
us a small amount of money and we go out
and do 30 inspections at New Hampshire
schools uh every year for uh make sure
that they're managing their asbestos
properly
just real quick the technical services
Bureau I already mentioned ambient air
monitoring with mobile sources program I
have a separate slide on that clean
energy we're kind of the technical arm
under the Reggie program puc handles uh
doe handles the money uh we handle the
technical side of implementing the
program same with RPS we provide
technical support to the RPS program and
legislation this group the technical
services Bureau is generally the folks
that come down here to see you folks
that includes Becky Mike and Joe and
Phil this year so we track March
legislation I think every year the Year
division probably tracks somewhere 50 to
70 bills depending on the year
not as much as we used to because there
is now a doe Department of energy we
were kind of in the past kind of I won't
say acted as a doe but we were probably
a little bit more involved in energy
issues but now that we have a doe we
certainly coordinate on energy issues
with them
um and obviously our role is to provide
technical information to policy
committees representative Summers has a
question
thank you Mr chairman quickly on the
Reggie program I know over the last 10
years it's been repealed and renewed how
much the percentage of that goes to New
Hampshire and what does it actually go
to so we have a whole presentation on
Reggie to go through right after I'm
done with this presentation could could
we wait for that
okay
representative Noel has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my questions
you're showing me at air quality
monitoring I assume that's outside air
is there an indoor air monitoring
program we used to have an indoor air
quality program we do not currently have
an indoor air quality program
um I think we had a small amount of
federal funds for that we lost that many
many years ago I think indoor air
quality may be handled by Department of
Public Health Services
more than us at this point
thank you
okay just
um just mobile sources I already
mentioned them largest source of air
pollution in New Hampshire and pretty
much the country
um some of our mobile Source programs
are the annual motor vehicle inspections
OBD everybody knows this says the check
engine light program everybody's
favorite program when they got to get
their car inspected uh that is in the
air pollution control program we have a
couple Grant programs deer a diesel
emission reduction act we get money from
EPA we match that money with VW money to
get bonus money and that helps change
out diesel projects across the state
would you generally go through a
competitive process and rank the scores
and things like that Granite State Clean
Cities Coalition this is a partnership
of well over a hundred Partners I think
Becky but the goal here is to reduce
New Hampshire's Reliance on fossil fuels
you know encourage alternative fuel
vehicles do a lot of Education Outreach
we're also work with transportation and
Regional planning commissions
foreign
so I quickly wanted to mention
Volkswagen New Hampshire got some folks
may remember back a number of years ago
Volkswagen was caught in a missions
cheating scandal I won't go into the
details of that but out of that
settlement New Hampshire got almost 31
million dollars uh put into an
environmental mitigation trust fund Des
became the lead Agency on that trust
fund in uh July this is August but I
I think it was July but I think the
actual paperwork went through in August
so so
um
we went through a we worked with oep
office of energy and planning back when
they existed before becoming part of doe
to come up with the mitigation plan in
this chart here shows the breakdown of
where the money is going to go 9.3
million dollars to Municipal 6.2 million
to State Vehicles there's going to be a
pool of competitive money and the one
that we're currently working on is the
4.6 million dollars for evsc that's
electric vehicle charging infrastructure
and then also administrative costs the
4.6 million dollars will come nowhere
near using that 4.6 million dollars for
administrative costs uh the admin costs
that we don't use will get rolled back
into the pot to be used for uh
environmental good looks like we have a
question
representative merner has a question yes
thank you on the 4.6 million that
money's been sitting there for quite a
while has any of it been spent yet
because all the other states have run
out of their money and I know that I
personally we had looked into some
funding for different stations in the
North Country yep uh I was working with
councilor Kenny on this and basically it
kind of got dropped there for a year a
couple of years ago so because we were
changing from Department of energy I
know there was a there was a few factors
I'm just wondering where we stand right
now because I get a lot of questions on
this yep so the next slide talks to that
so great question representative
um so we actually working with
um
um our partners at oep we actually did
do a solicitation a number of years ago
I don't remember what year Becky our
unsuccessful solicitation was
so in 2019 we did put on RFP and we got
zero
qualified responses so obviously
something went wrong there so we started
working with oep doe when they became
the lead and we did put out a
solicitation last year I think it was
October no October of 21. yeah so we
spent a significant amount of time
trying to perfect that RFP we we held
listening sessions to to we wanted to
get it right this time
so we did uh we I forget how many
exactly how many responses we got to
that RFP and with 14 projects were
selected and you can see the numbers
here all the projects are on our
designated alternative fuel corridors uh
this this represents 31 DC fast charges
and 13 level 2 charges we've gotten one
contract through governor and Council
and I've seen at least two more come
across my desk and we think we'll have
all those contracts done in the next
quarter
it is an absolute high priority for us
right now
yep we were a little bit behind the ball
we had that unsuccessful solicitation we
learned a lot from our neighboring
states we work closely uh you probably
heard of the term nescom before we part
of nescom is northeast states
coordinated air use management there's
six New England states New York New
Jersey uh we share information quite a
bit
um
that we are the amount of money that
went into this pot the 4.6 million was
the maximum allowed under the VW Trust
settlement that division came through
that decision came through the
governor's office obviously to maximize
that so we we put the full 15 percent to
that I will just also say that the
Department of Transportation also has a
plot of money called nevy I think that's
National Electric Vehicle initiative
so they have a part of about a little
over 17 million dollars to do something
similar to put electric vehicle charging
infrastructure and we've been working
with them and they've been working with
us because we're trying to coordinate
these two programs as best we can but
right now this money is out there and
it's going to be spent they'll start
spending their money probably later in
2023.
representative lewicki has a question uh
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question sure um do you have
any statistics on utilization rates of
the electric vehicle charging stations
um because I didn't really think about
it but as I came through the rest area
today uh this morning there were there's
a whole row of them there and I don't
remember there being a single car there
the the generally if it's at the rest
area it's probably the Tesla charges
those are significant those are only for
Tesla vehicles so anybody else driving a
non-tesla can't charge there I've seen
what you've described them before I've
seen none or I've seen them all being
used I want to turn to Becky I don't
know I know for the contracts we're
letting out for the for the EV charging
situations they will need the track and
Report utilization rates to us but
that's those are those are sites that
we're funding so we can easily make that
part of the contract I don't know if
there's other information
okay
representative Corman has a question as
well thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question sure uh
regarding these charges what types of
sites are they actually located at I
mean there are rest areas but but in
general what sorts of sites are we so I
think the for the 14 projects we've
selected some of them sites I believe
are Supermarket sites
um General Store sites so they're all
publicly accessible or else we wouldn't
be funding them
all right you guys got a lot of
questions today that's good
um just real quick major air qualities
in New Hampshire we've talked about
ozone ozone has historically been our
largest regulatory driver
um I don't need to beat that to death
I'm just going to jump through some
slides here on ozone in a minute
um find particulate matter has been a
challenge at times for us it's primarily
a wintertime wood smoke issue I post a
child for that in the past was the Keen
area which used to have a significant
air quality challenges with wood smoke
during the winter time we actually help
facilitate two wood stoves change Out
programs in the Keene area a number of
years ago and the levels of PM seem to
have come down we we used to issue air
quality action days we haven't had to
shoot an air quality action day for wood
smoke there in a number of years so
that's that's a good news story but EPA
is talking about revising that standard
uh Regional Haze this isn't a health
program I have a slide in this later on
it's really visibility of up in what we
call class one areas New Hampshire has
two class one areas that receive special
consideration under the federal Clean
Air Act and one of those programs is to
ensure that visibility returns to what
they call natural conditions by 2064. so
it's going to be well after I'm here
we're actually making very good progress
we've gone through two 10-year planning
periods on the regional Haze program and
I'm looking forward to being retired
before we have to do the third 10-year
plan so
it's a lot of work
the class one areas in case you're
wondering are up in the White Mountains
no big surprise these are Wilderness
areas over 5 000 Acres like I said New
Hampshire has two of them
uh just real quick ozone there's there's
good ozone in this bad ozone the good
ozone is the ozone up in our
Stratosphere that's what protects us
from UV radiation from the sun we all
used to hear about the hole in the ozone
layer my understanding that's getting
better
the battle zone is the stuff that's at
ground level it's it's not naturally
occurring it's man-made due to pollution
um it's it's nitrogen oxides and vocs in
the presence of sunlight so it's a
summertime issue
um you can read this but basically ozone
is bad for your lungs
um if you if you're a compromised
situation you have bronchitis you have
asthma ozone is going to make that
situation much worse it increases the
frequency of asthma attacks makes lungs
more susceptible to infection and New
Hampshire does generally have high
levels of asthma especially in our in
our children populations
one of the things we recognized and
somebody brought this up before and
that's the that's the question of air
pollution brought into the state we are
part under the Clean Air Act of what we
call the ozone transport region that's
these 13 states right here which goes
from most of Maine all the way down to
parts of Virginia and Washington DC the
Clean Air Act recognized that no
individual State can solve the ozone
problem it's a transport component to it
so there is an ozone transport
commission commissioner Scott sits on
that I generally go to the meetings as
New Hampshire's representative this
group can look at modeling it can look
at inventories it can look at what types
of control strategies we need and we
have in fact adopted some control
strategies consistent with the other
states in the region
this is a good new chart I mentioned the
Knacks those are the air quality
standards you can see this red line you
can see how the red line has changed our
period used to be 85 Parts billion then
75 parts per billion then 70 parts per
billion that's EPA revising the
health-based standard this looks at our
long-term ozone Trends in New Hampshire
and you can see there were times in the
past where we were above the red line
that's when we would have been in
non-attainment
so this is a I think this is a great
chart because it shows we're making
progress the the standards are getting
tighter but also our readings are
getting better so I think it's a good
news story
just real quick representative Doug
Thomas has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so um involving the EPA
standards that have been where the
standards have been reduced over the
years can you explain to me what
obviously we have better science but
what drives them to be able to lower the
standards uh in terms of um uh are they
going towards a particular goal has
science gotten better or are they just
lowering them because they can I I would
generally say that first of all there's
always controversy when EPA sets the
standards right some people think they
should be lower some people think they
should be less stringent
EPA has a very formal process
um they've they form a panel known as
ksac I don't recall exactly what that
stands for but they assemble a panel of
experts what those panels of experts
will do is evaluate health studies to
understand how a particular pollutant
impacts human health then based on those
studies based on their recommendation of
that committee EPA goes through a formal
rulemaking process which is a course of
public process
it it can EPA just proposed a new
NAX standard for PM
um they just put a proposal out right
around Christmas time I suspect it will
take them
at least a year to complete the
rulemaking process and then now we'll
start a three-year clock for New
Hampshire to evaluate where we are with
those standards
representative lewicki has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um
there must look in my mind be a
threshold level where of naturally
occurring ozone because ionizing
radiation and so forth and so how
clearly we're trying to approach that
but uh we're never going to get there
there is a natural level I guess you
could call it background conditions
where are the standard is above that as
as far as my understanding
um
the 70s standard has been in place since
2014 2015 EPA is currently looking at
the ozone standard I don't suspect
they're going to make another change at
this point
but I've been proven wrong many times so
all right fine particular matter to me
in a way this is a more challenging
pollutant because there are some health
studies out there that say any fine
particular matter is bad for human
health
um what is fine particularly it's a
complex mixture of really tiny particles
and liquid droplets on the left of this
slide is a human hair 70 microns so you
can see PM 2.5 and PM 2.10 are much
tinier than even a human hair so the
problem with that small of a particle is
it penetrates very deeply into the lungs
and can actually also penetrate into the
cardiovascular system so it's it it's so
small it has impacts not only in lungs
but heart health as well so
similar to the Chart we just saw on
ozone we can see real quickly here that
the changing in the ozone health-based
standard again good news story our
numbers are generally going down
I want to pick up the pace here because
I know we want to do Reggie too so um
Regional Haze again this is the program
in our class one areas
um
this shows on a good Clear Day
visibility range of 118 miles a bad
visibility day of 20 miles that's a hazy
day those aren't clouds that's air
pollution that's very fine particles in
the atmosphere either sulfur particles
nitrogen particles or even sea salt to
some degree that all impacts visibility
so it's not a health issue it's a
quality of life issue I mean everybody
wants to go up to the mountains and see
the mountains right we don't want to get
there and not see the mountains
um just real quick I want to hit real
quick some pfas slides uh RSA 20
125c10e requirements for Air emissions
this was the put in place obviously
because of the situation that occurred
down in Merrimack around the saint
Cobain facility it requires a number of
things to be done in those types of
situations I won't get into the details
other than to say what we're doing right
now is working uh diligently to make
sure that we're complying with the
statute there as you can see some of
this triggers off of if there are
ambient air ground ambient groundwater
quality standards so this is the first
time we've had a state statute that
looks at air depositing on the soil and
eventually getting into the groundwater
so it's kind of a unique uh situation
kind of unforeseen in the past so
um last year there was 20 20 22
legislation to require the department to
look at science what studies are out
there do we need to look at
strengthening any ambient air quality
standards we have for pfas we did do a
review uh this year uh led by Dr
Jonathan patelli and our environmental
health risk group and we made he made no
recommendations to adopt any new
standards simply because there's not a
lot of good science in this air in this
Arena about the inhalation risks of pfas
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair yes um back on the
pfas issue uh I understand that it is a
unique issue but I was wondering you
mentioned earlier that your department
does do enforcement in terms of air
quality and I'm wondering whether we are
engaged as a state solely in mitigation
of the problem or whether there's a
we've actually stopped them from
continuing to support uh emitting uh in
other words is it is it a continuing
problem or is it something that has been
um
addressed so there's a couple a couple
quick comments on that um back in 2004
the saint Cobain facility was found to
be emitting levels of
an ammonium salt of pfas I think it was
uh apfo or something like that which was
regulated under our air toxics program
and it the information we got from them
from doing some stack testing albeit it
was very
primitive stack testing at the time
because it wasn't a really good Federal
method to measure pfas in the air coming
out of the stack so they were required
to reduce the constant content of those
Coatings literally it could have been
from tens of thousands parts per million
in the coating down to like 75 parts per
million so that was the first step
then obviously we got into the situation
that we're faced with right now and
that's the contamination of groundwater
that
rsa125c10e one of the requirements of
that is if you cause or have the
potential to cause a groundwater of
exceedings you have to do what we call
best available control technology and
that's what we required Saint Cobain to
do they installed a regenerative thermal
oxidizer in place and that's been tested
twice successfully so
they are down to the point where they're
if releasing very very minor amounts
probably less than one or two pounds a
year compared to in the past when they
may have been as high as 900 pounds or
more so yes we've made a lot of strides
foreign
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair uh just
following up on on the previous question
recently Saint Cobain self reported that
the rtos failed uh and they admitted uh
17 pounds of pfas chemicals into the air
were they held accountable whereas there
were a financial fine and or do we rely
only on self-reporting
they well there's two things
um they obviously have to do monitoring
record keeping and Reporting on a
regular basis under their air permit
they have to report to us
what we call permit deviations the most
recent one may have been
in the last month they had they're
required to maintain a certain
temperature operating temperature in the
RTO and that's monitored across the RTO
and they dropped like 1.5 degrees below
the minimum required in the permit and
they reported that as a deviation that's
what they're supposed to do they do have
a bypass stack on the incinerator and I
know that's caused a lot of angst from
people who are currently evaluating the
bypass stack as part of their air permit
application to renew their permit so
we'll be beginning a public process on
that pretty soon
plus I mentioned we do require the
annual test of the incinerator they do
hire a third party person to do that
testing Des is on site we had two
seasoned veterans on site when they did
the test last fall
we oversee that testing we oversee what
the production processes are to make
sure the processes that they're running
are representative of what they're doing
on a daily basis so there is definitely
boots on the ground there
follow-up yes please when you are
referred to a failure creating angst to
people can you explain what you mean by
that oh I I obviously I when the bypass
stack first came to be known it was not
in the permit
um we determined that during one of our
inspections and I I think obviously
local people are concerned with making
sure that if they're going to continue
to operate that they operate in
compliance with their permits that's
kind of what I was alluding to
thank you very much
representative Noel has a question
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question
are pfas chemicals a component of the PM
2.5
matter that's being monitored
um there is there are ambient levels so
in the General Air there is pfas we know
it's a worldwide it's ubiquitous across
the environment at this point
um
so I don't know offhand if it I believe
it probably isn't a particulate form by
that point in time but I'm not 100
certain I would need to check on that
with my staff
uh this was a single Bane slide
um we've just mentioned we've already
gone through two rounds of Stack testing
uh we are going to be going out with
their operating permit public Hearing in
early 2023 so coming up shortly
we have tested a couple other facilities
well at least one other facility in the
state
um and no issues subject to similar to
what we've seen at St Cobain have we
found at those other facilities
all right my last slide before you get
to talk to Joe about Reggie
um EPA put out a strategic plan last
year to cover the
2022-2026 time frame they listed Seven
major strategic goals in that plan I'm
not going to go through all of them I am
just going to hit the top two though
climate change and environmental justice
and civil rights
I can't go to a call a meeting with EPA
with those two words those two subject
matters are brought up uh climate change
and environmental justice as part of the
IRA Bill inflation reduction act there's
a lot of money in there epa's still
trying to figure out how they're going
to spend some of it to be honest with
you they currently have six or seven
open dockets where they've asked
questions of people but how do we want
to invest this money in climate change
strategies how do we want to invest this
money in environmental justice and civil
rights EJ or environmental justice is
becoming a bigger and bigger issue
New Hampshire does not have an EJ
statute
we the department does have a civil
rights non-discrimination plan that was
just signed off by the commissioner back
in October I think it's a 17-page
document talking about how the
department will Implement its programs
and compliance with the federal title VI
civil rights law but there's also an
environmental justice component to that
so we will continue to to monitor that a
lot of what environmental justice
entails is what they call disparate
impacts and disadvantaged communities
um
disparate impacts and cumulative impacts
those are words that we hear all the
time from EPA but there's not a lot of
federal guidance on how you implement a
lot of these these uh these programs so
we're we're working closely we have an
internal team at DES looking at this
issue
we think it could come up in some
hearings we may have coming up for some
permanent facilities we're going to
continue to monitor that part of a big
part of EJ is make sure you do good
Community engagement meaningful
Community engagement if they're a
minority speaking folks make sure that
you you know putting out information in
their native language so they understand
what's going on
but the big challenge is going to be if
you find a disparate or cumulative
impact how do you define that and then
what do you do about it because there's
really nothing in statute as to how you
how you implement that so waiting for
some more Federal guidance on that
program it's a priority of the current
Administration
thank you director Wright uh
representative Doug Thomas has a
question
thank you Mr chairman
um
I've got a question that's
may not be widely accepted but
um
we recognize the fact that the uh that
the climate is changing uh and also that
we're doing everything we can to help
um get rid of the pollutants in the
years is but the climate is changing
anyway and so my question would be is
have you heard of any discussions within
the federal government on any monies
that could also be used to help us
prepare for the changing of the climate
in addition to the fact that we're
trying to reduce pollutants to maybe
slow it down but has there been any talk
about preparing how we can help
ourselves for the climate that is
changing so some some of the money
contained in the ira the inflation
reduction act I believe will go towards
not only
planning
mitigation but also how do we respond to
it you know how do we build uh better
infrastructure to deal with the change
in climate how do we do we look at you
know the size of culverts uh from from
Heavy Rain events which I think some of
us would agree that you know what we see
today is different than when I was a kid
I can say that unequivocably
um I recognize that weather changes year
to year but there does certainly seem to
be some component there that is uh
changing that's for sure
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman yes my question
was also I was waiting until you were
done with your slides to come back to it
on slide 21 the last bullet was under
major air quality issues was climate
change and clean energy and I wondered
why it was on that slide
um but you know I don't think you spoke
to it or had anything to say about it on
this committee I think from a policy
standpoint we look at bills all the time
uh that are proposed in order to either
have better planning around addressing
climate change or or bringing our
policies up to Snuff with what is going
on you know regionally internationally
and clean energy was listed there as
well so I was just wondering why that
bullet was there and if you could just
say a little bit about why it's under
under that I I think it's just a
recognition of
um if we're gonna if you're gonna deal
with climate issues you need to deal
with energy issues
um most of our missions that are related
to climate change CO2 are related to
energy usage rather it's in the
transportation sector in terms of uh
burning few we all burn I'm sure most of
us drove a gasoline car here today that
certainly has CO2 emissions
um so in my mind I think in the
Department's mind clean energy and
climate are interrelated but there's a
lot of benefits to clean energy not just
climate
clean energy also has other air quality
benefits as well
thank you
represented and I simply I'll apologize
I just skipped over that slide in my
haste but I knew climate was also coming
back under the federal policy side
because that is a huge priority for the
administration
and we've consistently told the
administration that
if you want to go down the road of
working in this area States would need
resources States can't do this without
boots on the ground and funding to do
some of the things that may need to be
done
representative Reynolds has a question
and ideally uh
leading at the federal level makes a lot
of sense to me at some level in some
ways because it is it's a national thing
more than just a state issue
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman my question was
just really a follow-on to
representative Thomas's question maybe
just try to elucidate a little more
more detail to what extent has Des been
involved
um you know since I was a city council
in Portsmouth I know that cities and our
cities
plant Regional planning commissions
around the state have been
um
making efforts to help localities adapt
to the changing climate
um
um you know
prepare their infrastructure make their
infrastructure more resilient to the
increased flooding and things like that
so
um to what extent has is des involved in
those or helping direct or helping funds
so there's a couple different areas we
can point to obviously in terms of
mitigation we're obviously part of the
Reggie program and you're going to hear
about Reggie
um Des kind of serves as the technical
resource on Reggie
we do all the Contracting with Reggie
Inc but that's getting into those
details that Joe will probably cover
um new we also provide support to the
renewable portfolio standards program in
New Hampshire there's a role for Des
there and certifying that sources are
meeting the emission limitations to
qualify for the wrecks
not so much the air division
um although we did have a position a
number of years ago that had a small
climate Grant
um through Homeland Security
um and that person largely worked with
like the coastal adaptation work group
Des is a big partner working with
Coastline communities and planning for
uh
resiliency and things along those lines
and we also were working with the Upper
Valley area as well but I will say we
don't have a lot of resources in this
area in terms of that's why I mentioned
one of the stress points we've given to
the administration is if you want work
in this area you need to fund it
there's there's all there's more that
can be done
hey I suggest we move on to the Reggie
program uh I'm sure Joe will be mindful
of the fact that uh the lunch hour uh
will be starting soon
great I will call up Joe's presentation
yep see they use the arrow keys too or
not uh
yep
yes you can
what's that yeah
good morning again my name is Joe
Fontaine
I have
been the department representative
managing the New Hampshire
portion of the Reggie program
since its Inception
typically the first slide of a
presentation is fluff
but on this slide I have the link to the
the Reggie website
it has a lot of good information I'm not
going to be able to cover everything
today so if you're interested in more
details about the Reggie program
I encourage you to go to the Reggie
website
foreign
so I wanted to start off with a little
historical perspective
New Hampshire does have a 2009 climate
action plan and one recommendation
of that plan was to implement Reggie
and the link to that website for the
climate action plan is is at the top
kind of small but it's there
um so in statute New Hampshire statute
one of the requirements is for
a joint report from the Department of
Environmental Services and now
Department of energy
to file an annual report and to
update the the legislature on
a number of allowances sold number of
allowances not sold which
all of them in recent years have sold
that there was a period in the early
years of Reggie where a few went unsold
um price data
Market monitoring reports again on that
Reggie website we have a market monitor
since the beginning of the program
there's been no evidence of
collusion or manipulative behavior on
the part of the bidders
maybe to back up a step I thought Craig
was going to include one slide on Reggie
in his presentation but basically we
have a diagram on
how Reggie works is
it's a program to reduce CO2 emissions
carbon dioxide emissions from power
plants and so there's a regional cap
each state has a budget that decreases
year after year
the allowances they're called which
represent one ton of emissions get
auction quarterly and at the end of a
three-year compliance period each power
plant has to have enough allowances to
cover its emissions
um there is a provision that at the end
of each year they have to cover half
their emissions
but I digress
um so
um
other other requirements of the annual
report are on emissions both state level
and Regional level and so I have a few
slides from the most recent report
this November
um
that I'll get to but I just wanted to go
over first
um as I said a little bit of historical
perspective
so
in the early years there were bills put
in to repeal Reggie
and I think
um
what the legislature has settled on is
what's referred to as contingent repeal
um if Massachusetts or two other New
England states
drop out of Reggie then there's
provision in the statute that New
Hampshire would drop out
um
that makes sense because if New
Hampshire were to drop out by itself it
would not have a large impact on
electricity rates
but New Hampshire would
forego any revenue from the Reggie
program and I'm I'm going to get to a
slide on the revenue so you'll see that
that is significant
so again
um going back in time in 2017
senator avard who was the Prime sponsor
of a bill to for a study committee to to
look at costs in the electricity system
and there's a link to that report of
that study committee but
one of the two are two of the major
findings of that report were
transmission and distribution costs are
increasing and Energy Efficiency is one
way to offset
some of those costs
so this is a slide from ISO New England
which I guess you're going to hear from
at some point but um
they do annually do forecasts
and
two of the forecasts are
now our transportation and heating
electrification and how that increases
the load
for the regional at the regional level
so that goes into the gross load and
then Energy Efficiency and
BTM is behind the meter
solar or distributed energy
um reduce the gross load and you get a
net load so you know this savings from
Energy Efficiency I think in the
presentation last week from the consumer
Advocate on crease he talked about
nanowatts negative megawatts and so
that's um
kind of shows how
it reduces the gross load to the net
load
another slide from ISO New England on
costs
um not it's hard to read and I'm not
going to go into detail on it but just
if you just look at the bar graph
um
the Reggie portion is a very small
portion
of the
overall cost for generation
and you know again this was talked about
last week I believe
um but electricity costs track natural
gas prices or fuel costs those are the
major component
that impacts electricity costs
so getting to some of the slides that
are in the annual report that doe and
Des
submit to the legislature
this is a slide on the New Hampshire
specific slide on the four different uh
utilities
and their typical bill
as of August 1st 2022
and you can barely read the the Reggie
portion at the top
the blue portion at the bottom again is
is fuel costs and you have transmission
and distribution costs are major costs
um
so
again from the annual report
doe commented that
the costs are very small about
a tenth of a percent
so in New Hampshire that translates to
about 21 cents per month
for the average residential customer
and the impact can be offset by
investment in Energy Efficiency
and the next slide I'm going to go over
is under current law
this is how the Reggie funds are
distributed
as I mentioned this quarterly auctions
so the four quarterly auctions together
from from last year were about 43
million dollars in Revenue
um that goes into the Energy Efficiency
fund so so Reggie sometimes people get
confused between Reggie and RPS
RPS the renewable portfolio standard is
renewable energy
the Reggie money goes into the Energy
Efficiency fund not the renewable energy
fund
um
and so the breakdown
is according to what we call the Dollar
threshold which was enacted a few years
back 2013 I believe
um
and so in 2022 there are roughly
3.21 million allowances sold
so only the first dollar of that goes to
the funding of the Energy Efficiency
programs
supplements the SBC
and uh
the remainder above a dollar goes to
Great payer rebates and
just the general rule of thumb we we
assume 60 40
UH 60 percent to
commercial industrial customers
40 to residential
so most of the money under current law
goes to
rebates repair rebates
um again from the annual report the last
I actually uh the report as I said was
in November there was another auction in
December so I added that in here so five
auctions
since the previous annual report
um so that's why the 55 million is a
little higher than the 43 million on the
previous slide
but um
auction prices
over that last five auction cycle range
from you know around thirteen dollars to
almost fourteen dollars Which is higher
than in in the past
so just the high level overview you know
Reggie started off
uh the first three years uh with a flat
cap and and then it gradually declines
um so it sends a predictable Market
signal that the regulated Community the
power plants can react to in advance and
and know what they and plan and know um
how much they can emit
um
and
at the bottom of the slide there there
again is mentioned of the um
dollar threshold for allowance is
rebated
so I think you're gonna
in this in the session you got several
bills that address
a possible amendment to that dollar
threshold
preview of coming attractions
um so I just wanted to again touch base
historically
um
we do at the regional level uh periodic
program reviews
roughly every four years five years or
so so the last one was done in 2016
actually finalized in 2017 I believe
and
um
the the recommendation uh for post 2020
through 2030 was to maintain a similar
Glide path
to the reduction slope that we were on
so at the regional level that's about
2.275 million tons
and
uh New Hampshire and Maine got a slight
deal
that they other states did additional
reductions in 2021
um and made in New Hampshire did not
and we did also did not do
an emissions containment Reserve that
seven other states did
so this slide goes into a little more
detail on that
um
the goal regionally was to get to 30
percent so
when I say New Hampshire got a slight
deal I think made in New Hampshire doing
about 29.1 percent so
um
but some of the other states did a
little bit more in 2021 so that
regionally we got to 30 percent
reduction by 2030.
uh in the cap
um
and
um now we're in the midst of another
program review
um started in 2021 ongoing
we'll be doing analysis again if you go
to the Reggie website on that first
slide you can sign up to receive emails
on uh
and participate in the process comment
if you want there are a number of
comments on there already
from the public
but um
so
one of the things that has been
some uncertainty about that
we hope to address in in 2023 2023 when
we
go through uh and complete program
review
uh which states are in which states are
out so
New Jersey originally was in the program
back 2009 to 2011.
uh then Governor Christie took them out
they came back in in 2020
uh Virginia
is in the program in 2021 and but there
new governor
um has said that they will be out by the
end of 2023
Pennsylvania
talked about coming in uh
they went to court
it's still in court we're waiting to get
a court decision by the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court as to whether
um they will come in uh they obviously
didn't come in in 2022 so I'm hopeful
that they come in in 2023 and also North
Carolina has talked about coming in
uh again 2023 may be ambitious for them
more likely 2024.
but in general the more states that are
in the program that reduces the cost for
the other states like New Hampshire's
costs could go down if it's spread out
amongst more States
so
um as I mentioned we're currently in
program review very possible
New Hampshire May seek another
um
deal on um
we I think we intend to make no further
cap reduction before 2031
the past program review went through
2030 so we want to give power plants
time to plan
for any changes that get made
uh
another requirement of the annual report
is emissions so this first slide on
emissions is New Hampshire emissions
and you can see there's generally a
downward Trend
um as I mentioned
um
2020 and 2021 2020 New Jersey is in 2021
New Jersey and Virginia are in so
those bars go up but that's because
there's more States in not necessarily
because
the nine state emissions continue to go
down so
at the top you can see that 2022 overall
budget
but this is for New Hampshire
um
was 3.8 million and the total emissions
the black bar
on the right
is a little higher than than 2 million
so we were well within the New Hampshire
budget
and then this is regional and this is
the
uh one where the the last two years
include more States
um so again Regional cap
2021 was 119 million
um almost 120 million and
the far right
Blue Bar
is um
below that so well within the regional
cap
so good story
on emissions
and just uh
my information and Mike who
apologizes couldn't be here today
feel free to call me or email me with
questions
and thank you I stayed within the time
frame you did an integrated great job
Joe we appreciate it we're getting
hungry
[Laughter]
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
um I'd like to go back to the your
previous Slide the six involving the
annual energy forecast which you said
you uh you obtained via ISO New England
information
um I have a question that will propagate
a follow-up the um the last column on
the right is that indicative of the
amount of energy that's going to be
needed in New England per
per year
yes so follow-up question
follow up thank you uh so is there a
another column or is there a slide that
shows how much energy production is
going to be available per year and I
don't mean what we have a lot of
proposals out there but we all know that
very few of them actually get approved
over time so is there any information
involving how much energy is going to be
available
per year to to be put with the slide so
that's one of the reasons why this slide
was was excerpted from an ISO report but
that's one of the functions of iso New
England to manage the grid so you know
annually that's what they're doing is
making sure that there's available
capacity
more than available to meet the expected
demand
um that so ISO and New England would
have that information
representative Reynolds has the question
thank you Mr chairman yeah this is just
a a pretty a pretty small question that
relates to second to last slide
on New Hampshire CO2 emissions from
applicable sources so this is showing us
that what we know there are really only
three power plants in New Hampshire
that are
subject to Reggie emitting carbon and
two of them I know are
Newington near where I live and then the
Granite Ridge I believe is the one in Mr
and representative Thomas's District
Londonderry and then what's the third
one so this is actually five plants five
plants um but there's three companies if
you will
um so there's Granite Ridge which is
just south of the Manchester Airport
which is a gas plant
this essential power Newington which is
also a gas plant and then the other bar
is a combination of the three
Granite Shore plants you formerly PS and
H plants so those are Merrimack station
Schiller station uh in Portsmouth and
Newington station
and am I correct those are the
coal-fired
so Newington is not coal-fired
um Schiller was coal-fired they
converted one unit to biomass but now
they don't operate at all
um and Merrimack is still coal-fired
operates infrequently and Bo in Boeing
okay yeah it's kind of confusing it's
Miramax station it's inbox yeah thank
you thank you Mr chairman thank you I
have a question Joe do the biomass
plants in the North Country Bridgewater
and Burgess biopower are they subject to
uh Reggie
currently they are not that's an
advantage to them they don't have to buy
allowances to cover their emissions and
the reason for that is we've generally
regarded biomass as uh
carbon neutral or mostly carbon neutral
in that trees grow in the forest and
offset the emissions
um
there in this most recent program review
we did receive
at least one comment that
um
those should be included in the program
and should have to buy allowances to
cover their CO2 emissions and that's
under review
um in the program review process but um
generally New Hampshire is regarded
biomass is carbon neutral not all states
do Massachusetts does not
okay thank you representative Wendy
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
um and thank you for being here this is
a good presentation the one dollar that
goes to Reggie can you um tell me how
that translates to energy cost wise to
Energy savings
so there was a formula one dollar equals
so much savings
um
so if it is spent on Energy Efficiency
there's been studies in the past that
um you know
investment in Energy Efficiency saves in
the long run
um
two to three dollars probably for every
dollar spent
um
if it's rebated
to repairs then they get that
well the dollar portion isn't rebated
but the other portion that's rebated
they get that amount of money rebated I
was referring to the Energy Efficiency
so thank you very much thank you
thank you
seeing no further questions or did you
have one representative McGee
representative McGee hi Joe this is just
for clarification I had heard that one
of the reasons to not get out of the
Reggie program is that states that are
part of the program continue to have to
pay even if they're not gaining benefits
from the program is that one of the
reasons that New Jersey got back in I
just was wondering how to view that
um not so much New Jersey that's true of
New England because New England has a
regional power pool and so you know if
New Hampshire drops out of the New
England region you still have five other
states certainly Massachusetts is
disproportionate share of that
um
so it wouldn't impact electric rates uh
very much for New Hampshire
New Jersey
um
I think got back in because they
recognized that action is needed on on
climate and they are part of the pjm
Pennsylvania Jersey Maryland which but
it's larger than that power pool
um so
some of the states in that power pool
are in some are out so it doesn't really
that that same uh
hypothesis or reasoning doesn't apply to
them as much as it does in New Hampshire
so follow-up yeah the follow-up is so
does that mean that we would still
continue to pay if we pulled out and not
receive the benefit is that accurate or
right so I mean
they're being
imperceptible decrease probably in
New Hampshire New England electricity
rates if if New Hampshire pulled out and
we would not get this
you know last year
43 million dollars in Revenue
so we would not be able to do either
Energy Efficiency or rate payer rebates
which you know Advantage New Hampshire
repairs
okay well thank you very much it's been
a very informative presentation as usual
by the department we really appreciate
you being here today
and uh I'm sure you'll be back to
testify on specific bills we'll look
forward to seeing you then
and with that
the committee will now go into recess
until one o'clock at which time we'll
have a presentation by The Joint
utilities eversource Unitil and Liberty
followed by a presentation by the New
Hampshire Electric Co-op so we will be
in a in recess until one o'clock
this is your one minute warning we'll
resume this meeting in one minute
okay everyone if you please take your
seats
we will resume
this meeting of the science technology
and energy committee we had a lengthy
presentation this morning from the
Department of Environmental Services
and now we will continue this afternoon
with some presentations from the
electric utilities who serve our state
we'll start out with a presentation of
uh
the four utilities led by eversource
and I will ask Mr locata to come forward
and Mr Foley and begin our presentations
before we start there I will make one
other quick announcement this morning I
said
or I reported to you that ISO New
England might not be here on Thursday
due to a an illness situation I
confirmed just a few minutes ago that
they will in fact be here on Thursday
morning so ISO New England will be here
Thursday morning at 10 30. and the New
England power generators will be here at
one o'clock in the afternoon
so with that announcement I'll now turn
the floor over to Mr locata
good afternoon uh thank you chairman
Vose uh members of the committee Michael
Licata uh representing eversource energy
again uh before you
um with me is Doug Foley who's the
President of Operations here in New
Hampshire we really appreciate the
opportunity and the invitation of the
committee to come in and give some
background information on how utilities
operate we usually do this jointly with
the other utilities this year we sort of
broke it up so you'll be hearing from
from all the different utility companies
distribution utility companies electric
and gas and we really view this as the
start of a conversation with all of you
we know you have uh I guess 42 bills uh
before you this year and we really hope
to be a constructive voice and uh and uh
Aid and sort of a resource for you as
you consider those public policy
discussions so with that I'll turn it
over to Doug Foley we're going to take
through a presentation and as we go
please feel free to interrupt and ask
questions as we work through the slide
deck
great thank you
um thank you um chairman and the
committee here for allowing us the
opportunity to to share you know a view
of eversource and the electric utility
here in New Hampshire as might get
indicated my name is Doug Foley I've
been in the industry for over 33 years
similar background that I have I've been
in operations those 33 years working
with our field crews in Massachusetts
forever Source
worked with the the overhead and
underground line workers a substation so
really run the whole full gamut of our
of the electric utility business also
serve the capacity as an Incident
Commander in Mass for the last 10 years
for major storms and major events and I
have a similar responsibilities here in
New Hampshire
sorry
I don't know if you want the screens on
chairman we did plug in I don't know how
to do that though
I don't know if it's just a remote over
here Chris Christie can you help uh
sorry I just noticed get them fired up
I wondered why the screens were dark I
assumed that you had chosen that uh
strategy but
yeah
foreign
we can see it okay
thank you
all right so um just a a high level
overview of of eversource so we
um
serve uh the distribution customers here
in New Hampshire about 70 of the
distribution customers so it's about 50
000 uh retail customers and serving over
211 communities here in the granite
state
um I'm going to get into a little more
details on my next slide but we have
about 14 000 miles of distribution
overhead infrastructure with a little
bit of underground infrastructure here
in the Manchester and Concord area we
have about a thousand miles of
transmission and the difference between
distribution and transmission is it's
its voltage and I'll talk about that in
in the next slide we have about a
hundred substations that essentially
converts high voltage power to usable
power across the granite state in about
300 000 polls that we own eversource
zones across the granite state of course
CCI and the other utilities that joining
me here also own some similar
infrastructure in this service territory
on eversource covers 5600 square miles
and across the state we have five
reporting locations or area work centers
where not only the line workers show up
and they're Associated uh supervisors
but we also have inventory engineering
customer reps also report regionally
our headquarters is in Manchester that's
where I reside and we also have uh
distribution system there uh dispatch
system which is both uh bulk which is
our transmission voltage and we also
have a distribution voltage uh
distribution system in Manchester and
that that group has the responsibility
to operate they have full visibility of
both Systems 24 7 and then they operate
equipment that we have out in the field
uh real time so for instance if there
was a an outage in a particular area or
there was a poll struck the First
Responders for that Community would
would call in to either our call center
The Dispatch Center and those folks in
the Dispatch Center will do some remote
switching and then also dispatch align
crew out there to make the repairs in
real time
here in New Hampshire we have about 1500
employees that support the New Hampshire
operation in the in the families of uh
of eversource
you know just kind of a high view of the
electric uh Network and I'm sure
everybody is well aware that um back a
few years ago we divested of all our
generating responsibility so we buy the
power off off the market
so essentially for for us the the system
is broken up into into three major
components you have the transmission
infrastructure which is the uh the
taller polls on the right-of-ways that
operate at a higher voltage typically at
69 000 up to 345 000 kilovolts
and then those have the ability to
travel long distances and input power
into into the region here in New
Hampshire
um they also
um give us the ability to bring any
Renewables typically Renewables that are
being developed whether it's it's wind
up on up in The Ridges of the mountains
or you know could be a solar operation
it's typically an area where there's not
a lot of load but there is a quite a bit
of um real estate to build different
generating uh DJ type infrastructure and
we utilize those transmission lines as
kind of the highway to get that power
into the load pocket where it's needed a
substation in its basic concept
essentially converts to higher voltage
and converts it to a lower voltage or a
distribution voltage and then we also
use substations for some transfer
capability both on the transmission
voltage system and on the distribution
voltage system that gives us some
redundancy in our operation
but a substation then converts it to a
distribution voltage which here in New
Hampshire we run a gamut but we have 34
5 so 34 000 volts we have some 12 000
volts and some four thousand volts and
there's a few others sprinkled in
between but those are primarily uh
distribution voltages and then those are
the those are the cables and the voltage
that run along the public way that you
see as you as you drive around the state
with the Transformers that converted to
residential and commercial and business
uses representative Doug Thomas has a
question
sorry I didn't see her but Wendy Thomas
was first so representative Wendy Thomas
you go first battle of the Thomas
Mr chair
um this is just a question regarding the
substations Across the Nation there have
been attacks on substations have you
increased Security on them or has that
incurred any additional cost thank you
yeah so the answer is so the answer is
yes we do have a few uh substations that
have robust physical security
essentially walls around some of the
infrastructure but we all our substation
infrastructure is is fenced in we
routinely have our workers out there
performing inspections and then of
course we're concerned about copycat
events so we get that information in
real time and we do some due diligence
to make sure
um you know do we see anything
suspicious or anything going on in the
particular areas that is a concern but
it is something that we continue to talk
about both in the industry and here at
here at eversource is that if you look
at a couple things that are occurring
you know we can know probably no longer
protect
substation infrastructure which is
simply a chain link fence in the case in
Washington in the case in South Carolina
and then there's the case in Metcalf
California is
um
you know customers or folks that want to
do harm to the economy you know can
simply just use a rifle and shoot
through the and shoot through the
equipment in one of those bulk
Transformers in general if you've driven
by one of our substations it's probably
a 24-month lead time to get that
material in so we all have spares on the
property maybe one or two and as I
mentioned earlier there's you can't have
a spare for all the different voltage
classifications that we have but it is a
little problematic if um if there was
some sabotage so it's one of these
things we're saying hey is there
something different we should be doing
in regards to physical security going
forward
thank you very much thanks
representative Doug Thomas has a
question now thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question
um as you probably can aware of the the
elf in the room here is the high price
of uh electricity but I I'd like to ask
a specific and I'm sure you'll cover
that later but I would like to ask a
question involving the transmission
costs for for a long time we've heard
people say that you know eversource is a
transmission costs are way too high
um
I'd like to have you speak to that
presumption and also what really is
entailed in the cost of a transmission
to to the residential rate payer yeah
thank you representative Thomas and I'm
happy to to answer that one and
obviously Doug can can add his thoughts
so when you look at
um a customer's bill and the different
uh charges they have to pay on a monthly
basis
um you know transmission accounts for
about seven percent of their bill
transmission is regulated by uh the ferc
through ISO New England who you'll have
in here on Thursday and
you know that charge uh on a percentage
basis has has increased quite a bit over
the past decade or so and one of the
reasons for that or one of the drivers
um is the uh retirement of a significant
amount of generation at the same time
and so investments in transmission allow
for the efficient movement of power
around the region to try to account for
that loss of generation in specific
areas that coupled with
um
uh you know the age of the system and
the need for Investments to uh continue
improvements in reliability so while the
increase in the overall percentage of uh
of costs on a customer's bill you know
increasing uh transmission charges has
gone up and up considerably it still
accounts for a relatively small piece of
a customer's bill by comparison the
Energy Service rate the default service
rate is around 67 percent of a
customer's bill
as I'm sure folks are aware
um eversource is one of three
transmission providers who operate in
the state of New Hampshire uh the other
two being National Grid and New
Hampshire transmission is a subsidiary
of next era which operates around
Seabrook so I hope that's that's helpful
continue up Mr Summers representative
Summers has a question thank you Mr
chairman it's not a question I was going
to see if they had a copy of their slide
deck for for me
I I you know I thought I had put them up
there but if not I apologize okay
sorry I got I got it wrong one thank you
appreciate it we do have some extras up
here as well
right and uh just to sort of round out
this slide
um as Doug had mentioned uh through
electric restructuring the company has
divested of its generation resources
you'll have uh New England power
generators Association uh in on Thursday
which can speak to their third party
ownership of generation we just talked
about transmission and really the focus
of our
um presentation today is is on the
distribution system
and the operations
yeah and I'll just
you know I'll just add one point
um
you know and it's depicted here in this
graphic but the you you know all
electric utilities used to be vertically
integrated so we would propose to build
generation to serve the load or the
forecast the load or meticulate region
so typically from the generating plant
higher voltage larger wire bigger
infrastructure all the way out to where
the load is you know and as uh
generation uh plants have retired in the
region it puts more Reliance on the
transmission infrastructure in order to
move that that that electricity around
not only New Hampshire but the entire
region because we are interconnected
which you'll learn more about on
Thursday so
representative Corman has a question
yeah so since you brought up the load
there's loss in the transmission lines
and in the distribution lines uh how
does that correspond to just the the
actual demand load
yeah I don't know what opposcent losses
are that's something you know we could
take back as an action but certainly you
know all electrical equipment in the
transmission distribution substation is
associated losses uh with the way you
magnetized a
you know the the Transformer itself so
um I think we have information like that
in the frick form one I just don't have
it memorized but we can Circle back with
this
great
moving on to the next slide so you know
one of uh I like to say a major goal if
folks say well what do you do for a
living
um and what I like to to share is that
essentially my responsibility and my
responsibility uh within the operation
is to to make sure that the lights don't
go out so we continually do inspections
and maintenance and make sure the
infrastructure not only is reliable but
resilient for for any particular storms
and when the lights do go out I think
there's two important pieces one is we
want to restore as quickly as possible
and as important we want to get
information to our customers as quickly
as possible and I'll talk about the
communication piece in a minute
but over on the over on the quadrant on
the right hand side
eversource there's a bunch of Matrix
that we that we track as an industry and
also at eversource but in 2016 our
customers in New Hampshire averaged
about One Outage every nine months
and as of the close of business in
December our customers are experiencing
outage every 20 months
and then when the lights do go out we
measure that outage in minutes
and again in 19 and 2016 we're about 132
minutes per outage and now we're a
little bit over an hour at 63 minutes
so what do we do to to get that type of
performance
you know I think it's just doing some
fundamental inspection and repairs of
the distribution and transmission assets
but in this case we'll talk about
distribution so the wooden poles the
wire
very important to replace
um the polls with uh as they Decay over
time also
um increase the type of wire the way we
construct our poles traditionally we
have like an open wire type construction
we use a a more compact type
construction that makes it robust during
wind storms and the ability to um
to repel any limbs that that come down
from from above and I have a slide on on
vegetation in a minute
um
but I think the customer experience fuel
outages as a result of all of these
types of Investments and when we do
communicate to the customers we give
everybody an ETR
that comes from our Dispatch Center so
when a call comes in the dispatcher can
see it in real time using some of these
smart switches they're able to send that
information out to the cab of the truck
right to our First Responders and then
they um they arrive on the job site and
they establish what repairs are going to
be needed and send that information back
to dispatch Center and then we share
that on our website to our particular
customers letting them know when the
when the lights are going to be back on
you know vegetation
um is the number one cause trees is the
number one cause of outages here in in
New Hampshire
um as I think you all know New Hampshire
is the second most forested uh covered
state in the in the country so there are
quite a few trees we're on a five-year
cycle so we go out and all our
distribution infrastructure we inspect
and travel it down every five years and
do a do a major trim and our goal is to
to look up and eliminate some of that
canopy so when it we do get these windy
days the there's a higher probability
that we won't see any any limbs come
down and then on an annual basis we do
remove about 15 000 hazardous trees so
these are trees that are either diseased
or at the end of life that could fall
down at a windstorm and then take down
our infrastructure you know and one
thing that's that's interesting to point
out is that we have miles and miles of
of circuit and a circuit itself could go
for tens of miles and you know we want
to trim the entire circuit but we could
if we get refusals from a particular
customer to do some trimming around
their particular home or a business you
know that one limb could impact all
those customers on that particular
circuit so you know we're
I think my I think my um my point to
this particular side is vegetation
management is as important of all the
electrical infrastructure that we
maintain invest in on the distribution
and transmission system
representative Corman has a quick
question for you thank you Mr chairman
uh my questions on the previous slide
where it said that 47 of customer
outages are restored in under five
minutes from the control room and I'm
curious how how what what's done for
that is this just rerouting power
through some redundant circuit yeah no
thank that thank you it's actually a
it's actually a great question and a
great story so back in 2016 if you think
about the distribution infrastructure
and that's the infrastructure you see as
you drive to and from work and drive
from your home
we had back in 2016 about 80 what I'll
call Smart switches so these are devices
out on the pole tops that give
information back to the Dispatch Center
in regards to voltage current and then
any fault that may occur like a struck
Pole or a tree limb coming down over the
years we've added up to just recently
we're at about a little over 1800 spot
switches that are that are in the air so
utilizing the control center at
Manchester our dispatches have real-time
information in regards to power flow and
what's happening with the system so they
have the ability to reroute power in the
event of a fault like a tree limb coming
down
and as a result of them
rerouting the power and using the
Investments that we've made just using
technology we're able to restore almost
50 percent of our of our outages are
within five minutes
then then what we do is we pinpoint with
that information we can pinpoint exactly
between two devices where we believe the
fault is and then dispatch our line
workers out there to make the repairs
follow-up
follow up thank you
um given that you have the smart
switches and the smart switches are
communicating this information why do
humans even need to be in that Loop
I'm sorry why do humans even need to be
in that Loop
so
um
so I think humans at the end of the day
are you talking about the repairs or
dispatch
information so I'm talking about the
actual repairs right because the smart
switches have the information they they
report that there's a fault yep and
there's a human making a decision as to
how to handle that fault that seems like
something that could be done
automatically and much faster without
even getting a human involved yep no
great question so
um our design philosophy is to put a
switch in between every 500 customers so
when we isolate a fault that's between
two devices or two smart switches on
average it's going to impact 500
customers
but the smart switches have the ability
to do what referred to as self-healing
so they know what the power flow looks
like very quickly they can sense where
the fault is they can open off and close
in and reroute the power without our
dispatches doing anything and our
dispatchers can view it real time on the
computer screen but then they'll need to
dispatch a line worker out to make the
repairs to make the physical repairs
representative Noel has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question on your vegetation
page you have on your last bullet item
an individual refusal can cause an
outage what is a refusal so we work
closely with the the tree ones and the
municipalities and you know some
customers just love their trees and it
may not be a tree that is in the public
right away it could be a tree that's in
on private property that could pose a
threat to not only to their flow of
power but all the customers on that
particular circuit and it's really just
illustrating a point that
um you know the support of the
communities and the tree world is a very
important to ensure that we have a
reliable distribution system you know as
I pointed out in the first bullet tree
related outages uh the number one cause
for all the good work we're doing it's
the number one cause to our outages we
average about a hundred blank tree Crews
you know in order to do a five-year
cycle it's about a hundred tree Crews
every day while doing the needed tree
trimming just to keep up with vegetation
thank you
and actually just to add to that it was
a point I was going to make as I think
um
members of the committee who have been
here uh in the past know that tree
trimming customer notice can often be a
passionate and Hot Topic so we
follow the puc rules on notifications
and what trees were allowed to trim uh
but you know they're
as Doug said uh folks love their trees
and so as you get constituent concerns
and and questions you know please feel
free to to direct them to us we're happy
to um uh to try to provide a response uh
as as best we can to any issues that may
arise and I I should have said this
earlier in the um presentation but uh
you know Doug and I are presenting
eversource information and figures
um but a lot of these programs are uh
true across all of the utilities
investments in smart switches and and
the grid vegetation management uh so
we're providing our story but uh it's
again I'm sure you don't want to hear
every utility come up here and say the
same thing over again so we're a bit
representative on this as they will be
on other programs as well
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um the these smart switches I understand
that they alert you for any kind of an
outage are they also used in planning
distribution
are they used in distribution planning
in regards to
how much goes where
yeah
um so we use them we do use them for
power flow in the distribution system so
one of the concerns is if we see an
increased use in a particular area of
the circuit depending on the physical
wire size if it relates if there's too
much current or too much load in that
particular area you could burn down some
wires so typically in high heat type
events like in the summer we might see a
load increase on a circuit and we have
the ability using the switches to
reroute power in order to make sure we
don't burn down the physical wire that's
in the field
thank you very much
representative Noel has a question
thank you Mr chairman
the smart switches are they are you are
you acquiring them as a result of POC
rules or is it an economic decision
you're making to acquire those smart
switches
so I'm not aware of any you want to
answer that first yeah I I can take a
crack at that so
um
traditionally the operation of the
system and decisions around reliability
are are something that a company makes
the the utility makes
the Public Utilities Commission then
through rate cases will review uh the
prudency of those Investments so are we
you know quote unquote gold plating the
system what is the benefit that our
customers are receiving from those uh
Investments is it worth that investment
so
um you know we operate the system we try
our best to make obviously prudent
Investments That Then are subject to
review by the Public Utilities
Commission and if they were to determine
either our reliability is not equal to
uh their their standards what it should
be then obviously we would have a
discussion with them or the inverse
being you know a your reliability is
really good but maybe you know it's not
worth the the price that you're putting
in so there's there's a balance once
there
thank you representative Summers has a
question
thank you Mr chairman this is just a
quick question on power generation and
that's what the eversource of with
Christmas Eve being the way it was and
with mystic not generating any power
does eversource have the capability to
be able to increase generation in those
period of times or does it helps the iso
to decide who what how much they provide
uh so
it really is an ISO decision in terms of
managing the transmission and just and
uh generation system so during the event
that happened on Christmas Eve we were
communicated in close communication with
ISO and had that situation continued to
increase they would have directed us to
take certain steps to reduce load to
make sure that the system remained
viable but we don't have the ability to
bring on additional Generations since we
don't own any generation anymore our
role at that point would be to reduce
load through you know what's called
managed outage outages
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
coming in today just a quick question on
the um on the vegetation management do
you have a program where you're um
replacing trees that you're removing
so uh I'd like to turn
okay
um so uh we
we try to work with the customer
um you know if we're removing a tree
entirely we are arborists have a program
called right tree right place to direct
them to species that won't grow up into
the line so think of like an ornamental
crab apple versus a white pine
um you know the company doesn't uh
unless we violate the rules and have to
sort of make it right uh that we don't
pay for uh replacement trees but we do
try to work with the customer and direct
them to you know the Audubon Society and
others who uh might have have free trees
that they're offering follow up thank
you
um I guess that was one part of my
question the other part was do you have
a program maybe it's a a little bit
broader where you know you're not place
you're not planting trees on the prop at
the property that you remove the tree
but maybe if you take 5 000 trees out a
year you're planting 5 000 trees in the
forest somewhere yeah so
to the best of my knowledge we do not
have a program in place like that
however the company does have an an
internal goal of carbon neutrality by
2030 and I know that there are
conversations going on internally about
a program like that we obviously take
down a lot of trees and or trim a lot of
trees I should say as part of our
reliability efforts and uh whether there
are opportunities to to offset that with
other protecting resources or planting
new resources I know is something that
our sustainability group is discussing
thank you representative barishni has a
question
I guess it's more of a comment but um or
it could be a question
what percentage of the work that they do
with tree trimming is actually cutting a
tree versus tree trimming I assuming
it's mostly tree trimming and very
little cutting of actual trees yeah I
would say majority of it on a percentage
basis is is tree trimming itself
um as I stated earlier on that slide I
believe it was yeah 12 to 15
000 what we call hazardous trees that
were identified on an annual basis that
we remove the entire tree and then we
work with as Mike had indicated the
different communities and the tree
wardens so we will replace some
vegetation and then there's good
vegetation that typically doesn't grow
up it grows you know in or around that
you know Services some blockage so we
work with the the tree wardens to
identify those opportunities
representative merner has a question
yeah I just want a quick quick comment
uh one of my places up at the Milan area
the last couple of years we will
constantly for the last seven eight
years losing power all the time and the
work that was done there with the tree
trimming with a 110 and all the back
roads a b you had a tremendous amount of
work done up the last couple years and
it's made a huge huge difference and the
other thing Friday night I'm sitting at
home and somebody hit a pole down in the
other part of the county I was in and uh
they call me and says we're going to
shut your power off in an hour
fix it you'll be out for so long and
then back on I've never had that call
ahead of time an hour before they they
were going to shut it off and I just
want to say that uh this program has
gotten better and better each year
because we're not up in the Milan area
it was we were we were out at least once
a week
a Wednesday a little Windstorm when we
were out so uh it's it's doing a really
good job I just want to make a quick
comment on it no I appreciate that
representative and then and the numbers
indicate and you know we share it with
the with the puc and the doe but you
know the Investments that we're making
are paying dividends it's keeping the
lights on when they go out we do have
the ability to get them back on on
quicker and in a slide that we have
coming up uh we've been doing a lot of
work and customer notification space so
some customers like to have phone calls
or go to the website or social media or
even be text so well you know I might as
well touch on it right now is that
um
each one of the line workers the field
workers in New Hampshire you know have
an iPad so the dispatcher can send that
information out to them and it
eliminates a phone call but though the
line worker will go out to that location
identify the problem but be pride of
making work they'll call back into the
dispatch and they'll establish an ETR
and if the customer chooses to get that
information we push that and say hey
we'll have your lights back on within
two hours and oh by the way you know it
was a it was a poll strike and then once
we the Line crew calls back in talks to
the dispatcher we close out that ticket
and then we push another notice out to
you and say hey your light should be
back on if it's not give us a call
um so I appreciate your comments I've
been working real hard as I said earlier
you know getting the lights back on
communicating with the customers is
probably equal as important and we're
getting similar comments like that all
the time so thank you
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm I'm thrilled to hear that
eversource as a company has a an
internal goal of carbon neutrality by
2030.
seven years away uh that's terrific I
assume that you're referring to your
internal your operations uh and I'm
wondering if those are the values
underlying
eversources operations corporate
philosophy does any of that philosophy
uh
extend to the carbon content of the
power that you procure for all of your
customers from the generation Fleet
yeah I can uh take a shot at that so
um that is correct it's an internal
operational uh goal so you know think
about our Fleet of trucks
um how we power our own
um uh buildings and Facilities
um in terms of uh the power that is
provided to our customers who elect to
take default service from us you know
that is actually a very
um prescriptive uh
uh structure that is contained within
State Statute as well as puc rules so
truly we um as you heard last week from
the Department of energy the and
um the consumer Advocate every six
months we go out and we procure power uh
on behalf of customers who who wish to
take default service we get those bids
back from the market whatever the price
is or the lowest cost uh makeup of that
generation it is passed through to our
customers now there is public policy
that is layered on top of that whether
it's the regional greenhouse gas
initiative which you heard about from
the Department of Environmental Services
this morning or the renewable portfolio
standard so those are public policy
decisions that we comply with but we
don't have the authority in stature
today to sort of go outside of that
because it would be potentially deemed
an imprudent additional cost
and we have several more slides to get
through and we know we have several more
utilities to get through so we'll we'll
try to pick up our Pace to make sure
we're staying on time
thank you
all right I'll uh I'll move this along
but we do have a full-time staff um that
is focusing on emergency response and
emergency response is just not storms
but it's physical assets as we discussed
earlier cyber business continuity Etc
um we utilize
um
you know we file a plan with the doe on
an annual basis we just made some
um some updates uh last week and we and
we did file that to New Hampshire doe we
used that for a similar framework across
the companies we use we follow the
national Incident Management System on
nins it's the incident command
infrastructure that's used it's
something that was developed following
the first uh World Trade Center bombings
uh back in the 90s you know it allows
organizations both internally with
municipalities and and state officials
to communicate with like people
Operations Logistics planning
Etc and then the framework that we use
here in eversource it gives us the
ability to kind of expand our response
to an event you know in the in the case
of a storm very easily we can bring
resources up from Mass in Connecticut or
from Mutual Aid and kind of bolted on to
our our response plan because we have a
consistent way we respond to system
emergencies
you know our restoration philosophy is
is very simple it essentially has four
steps to it we deal with first any
life-threatening Public Safety type
hazards like block roads why is down
poles down uh trees down the ability to
get First Responders in those
communities to to emergencies that's our
number one priority then we need to
re-establish the backbone make sure the
transmission any damage to transmission
infrastructure and or the substation are
up and running and and functional we
might not have all our contingencies in
place but establishing that back
backbone is is Step number two then we
focus on critical facilities sewer
treatment water schools Hospital fire
and police departments that need power
warming stations
etc those critical infrastructure and
then we focus in on the blocks of
customers so the largest number of
customers on a particular outage
typically gets gets our gets our
attention and our resources first so in
that stage in the in stage number four
and in all of the stages we're actively
restoring hitting critical
infrastructure we're also restoring
primary wires down but we also have a
group of employees and contractors that
are focused squarely on services so tree
limb takes down from Pole to house we
don't wait to the end of the storm we
try to do those in in parallel we think
it shaves about a day off our
restoration curve
foreign
you know communicating to our
stakeholders our external stakeholders
about our etrs what's our restoration
plan for for a given storm and the way
our customers want to be communicated to
so there's essentially many many
different Avenues but we communicate
prior to an event based on the forecast
and what we think the threat level is
and we have some some models that we use
to help us predict the number of
resources and durations a storm
um might have on our system we
communicate during the storm all that
critical information and then certainly
a feedback loop at the end of the storm
but our customers can can call in they
can call into police and fire they can
go to our website they can opt in either
through emails or they could get text
messages
um to and from their their mobile
devices
and just to add two quick notes here
um in additional in addition to the
customer Communications that Doug just
talked about uh the company has really
done a lot to improve Communications
with our municipalities so that there is
constant feedback and updates as to what
we're doing what our preparedness is and
then get getting their feedback as Doug
said on on locations of warming stations
the the length and duration of the
outage and in addition to that uh I'm
sure many of you were inundated by
regular Communications for me during the
last two storms uh to your legislative
accounts it's important for us knowing
that you guys are are public figures and
your constituents will be asking you
questions to make sure you know what
we're doing how we're how we are
responding and also uh what our
anticipated times of restoration are so
uh it's really a very robust program
that we've um put a lot of time effort
and resources into improving over the
past several years
you know in closing you know I would say
that you know our Focus here at
eversource certainly my focus is to live
a top tier
um service to our our customers so it's
making sure the lights are on and then
communicating when they when they do go
out and we work on that every single day
we have an operations meeting where we
our team and Engineering get together
every morning to look at look at how the
system's operating and look at any
potential issues that are
forward-looking over the next 24 hours
we continue to make what I would
consider some really good Investments
I'm using newer Technologies not only
has it got the lights back on but it's
also prevented a truck roll so if we can
prevent the truck roll you know lends
itself to to the greenhouse gas
component because we don't have the
diesel truck riding on out there and
then we can also make sure that the work
that we have planned for the next day
gets accomplished because we didn't have
to bring resources in you know in the
middle of night to make that repair you
know I'll leave you uh kind of with one
note
um you know out of all the good things
that that we're doing in the community
in our presence in the community one
thing that we're proud of and it's about
a six-year partnership with Manchester
Community College but we've identified a
need to develop the next Workforce of
the future and of course we have a lot
of co-op programs with UNH and other
institutions and you get your
traditional engineers and accountants
and and those folks that make the
business go on but we early on developed
the need to Homegrown here in New
Hampshire uh the craft workers uh the
line workers that are going to live and
and work here at eversource and in New
Hampshire about six years ago we started
an apprentice program with a with
Manchester Community College we hire
about 30 new line workers on an annual
basis that's my plan this year and
starting in January a second program we
have a Manchester Community College that
just got accredited it's in a substation
organization so it's a full associate
degree we bolted on a couple of
electives and when they graduate from
that program it's one of the programs
that they can consider revisource and we
consider them to work in our substation
group
foreign
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um eversource obviously is an electric
company what percentage of your truck
Fleet is electric
so we um I don't know the percentage but
I can tell you some of the things that
that we're doing so we are we are
electric gas and water across the three
states here in New Hampshire we are 100
electric so it all depends on the use of
the vehicle so meter reader meter
reading for example they typically work
an eight-hour shift so it could be
compressed natural gas or some electric
vehicles because that lends himself to
kind of a one ship one shift operation
you could plug it in off hours and then
you can utilize it the next day but we
have what I consider hybrid so a lot of
the line trucks or all the new line
trucks as we um you know a trip the
fleet they are diesel but they all have
a battery pack so when a crew arrives
they drive out to the job using the
diesel engine but when they arrive on
the job majority of the work if not 100
of the work they perform that day is off
of the battery so so the diesel shuts
off the line worker can Ascend and
descend and do all the work Associated
up in the poll and then you know drive
home on diesel at the end of the day and
that gives us ability to fully utilize
that asset both on Bluesky endurance
long storm events
follow-up yes please um do you have a
percentage of those hybrids
we can get you that yeah thank you
well thank you that's been a a really
good overview and I guess we have a few
more questions I know I have one but
I'll recognize representative Doug
Thomas first
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um last year uh aerosaurus gave a
briefing uh on the iso New England
notice of um future potentials for
Rolling blackouts and the uh my my
question is
since then has anything changed from
eversource's preparation on the briefing
that they gave us and have all of the
communities in New Hampshire in your
service area been contacted to see what
steps that they may want to plan for
should something happen like that
yeah uh thanks for the question
representative so uh to answer the first
one
um given
uh the continued and I would say
increasing warnings from ISO New England
going into this winter
um we have been preparing
um
and doing exercises both internally and
in coordination with with the iso and
Regional Partners so that we understand
the flow of communication what would
need to be done in the event of of a um
of a call for reduced or I should say
controlled outages so we have been
continuing to refine our process plan
and work with
um Regional stakeholders including the
ISO in terms of communication to our
municipalities I think it was maybe one
or two months ago we hosted a webinar
where we invited all of our all of our
municipalities to attend explaining the
situation
um and what might happen in the uh
hopefully unlikely event of a call for
uh reduced load so so we have
um that's the second straight year we've
done that briefing for municipalities
and we will continue to do so and and
work with them to answer their questions
uh as long as this remains a concern
follow up
thank you again
um I know uh last year I think I was
perhaps one of the first ones to present
that presentation with the assistance of
eversource in front of my Town Council
and I got raked across the coals on why
we allowed this to happen have you
perhaps put out some more education on
why we are in this situation to the
municipalities and to the people so they
fully understand just how how we got
there yes
um the short answer to that question is
yes uh we do
um try very very hard to educate our
customers on the cost drivers that have
led to
um the the increase in their electric
bills that that hit back in August uh
which are you know largely Regional in
nature and tied to you know Global
economics
um as you heard last week from the
Department of energy and uh I think the
consumer Advocate as well it is a
challenge uh to to sort of cut through
the noise and um uh have folks
understand that at the end of the day
um you know it's our name on the bill
that gets and so to try to explain as I
did earlier that this is a pass through
this is you know Regional natural gas
prices that are affected by global uh
commodity prices it's it's difficult to
um to make that case but we do try very
hard using all of our communication
channels to do so
follow up sorry I'm sorry I I must have
miscommunicated my my question was about
the um uh
the iso New England's notice about
potentials due to lack of capacity in
the future that's what I was referring
to in terms of explaining to people of
why we're in that position I
understood
um most of our Communications on that
topic have been focused at the municipal
leader level as opposed to
um at the customer level there is a lot
of opportunity for
confusion uh we don't want to
unnecessarily
concern folks the iso has done a good
job of putting out press releases and
there has been a number of news stories
on you know their winter Outlook so we
do work in coordination with them on
that but
um you know it's it's a balance uh for
sure about you know the detail that you
the level of detail that you go out with
that with those Communications
so the public the general public is
hungry
for knowledge to help to help them
understand why their electricity bill
has gone through the roof over the
course of the last eight months
is there anything that you can say
in a
relatively straightforward not too
complicated manner about what ever
Source might do to prevent
another huge spike in electricity
prices now I know there's a procurement
docket before the puc
can ever Source say anything about the
possibilities for procurement that could
prevent the kind of rate shocks we got
this past August yeah
thanks for the question representative
um
ultimately what is driving
the rates so significantly higher so
quickly
uh is essentially there is not enough
reliable Supply in the region to meet
the demand uh during the winter time
um the vast majority of
um
power generation I shouldn't say the
vast majority but the majority of power
generation in New England uh comes from
natural gas and so natural gas-fired
power plants and so in the winter time
uh when that natural gas is directed
towards eating people's homes and
businesses as the committee knows uh we
have to rely on on other fuels to make
up that difference which tend to be less
efficient and more expensive but
absolutely critical at this stage for
the continued operation of the system so
if folks will recall back around uh New
Year's Eve we were running for multiple
days of over 40 percent
on on oil so there really are
um supply and demand issues there and so
we want to be a constructive voice as
this committee and the senate committee
and the legislature and the governor
um continue consider options going
forward to bring additional Supply
diversify our supply while also
providing incentives for our customers
to reduce their usage through Energy
Efficiency so
unfortunately there aren't a lot of
short-term answers in the short term we
are working very hard to communicate
with our customers about programs that
the legislature has passed the federal
government has passed to help them pay
for their
utility bills or defer the cost of their
utility bills but ultimately
um
we are certainly supportive of policies
that bring additional Supply on and help
to uh you know manage the demand uh so
that we can uh you know successfully
um navigate this you know Regional
transition away from uh base load fossil
power plants to more intermittent uh
Renewables
so the
short answer is you don't see any
short-term procurement changes that
could ameliorate the
violent ups and downs of energy costs
there are things that
um can be done in the I'll say short to
mid term around procurement and one that
gets often talked about is a concept
known as laddering so as I mentioned
previously every six months we put out
our full customer load there is
maximum
uh Market exposure at very specific
points in time and you know even a few
weeks one way or the other could could
make a difference in the price that we
get back from the market and ultimately
charge our customers so one of the
things that other states have done is to
break up that load break up those
procurements say a third a third a third
so if at any one point in time there is
Market uh shock going on for whatever
reason you're sort of only have a third
of your your load that's exposed to that
and so it ends up being a blended rate
that helps with price stability But
ultimately does not help with reducing
the cost of electricity because you're
still procuring from the same Market
that is is very volatile so that is a
concept that I know that is under
consideration at the Public Utilities
Commission as part of their
investigation docket but something that
could be done in the short term to try
to stable lies prices and smooth out
those those price shocks
there is legislation in the Senate that
was heard this morning to allow for
power purchase agreements
um you know I think that would take time
to to get that running up and running
but uh that could be
um
long-term contracts could provide a form
of financial hedge against Market
volatility if you're locking up a rate
for a longer term of time that's a
portion of your supply that you might
not have to go out for procurement so it
can provide a hedge other Utilities in
New England as well as in New Hampshire
the Electric Co-op is here have policies
that allow them to do that as it stands
today the utilities don't have those
those tools at their disposal as were
regulated by the commission
okay I'm sure committee members have
additional questions but I'm going to
ask them to hold those questions and
maybe ask them of the other utilities so
that everybody gets a fair shot here to
uh to represent themselves so thank you
to eversource we appreciate that
and since you guys have been kind of
coordinating this joint utilities
presentation I'll let you tell us who's
next
uh Unitil will be joining us uh briefing
you next uh and I'll let them come up
and introduce themselves great thank you
very much
foreign
good afternoon everyone thank you Mr
chairman for the record my name is Kat
Burke I'm the director of government
Affairs at Unitil uh with me today I
have Cindy Carroll she's our vice
president of customer Energy Solutions
as Mike mentioned earlier uh this is a
joint presentation but we did divide up
a lot of the sections that have
significant overlap for the utilities so
I'll be giving you a brief overview of
Unitil as a company today and then I'll
be passing it over to Cindy who will be
discussing New Hampshire's Energy
Efficiency programs
I just want to confirm you all have a
copy of the presentation in front of you
correct
okay great
um so Unitil isn't a regulated electric
and Natural Gas Distribution Company we
were founded as the company that you all
know today in 1984 and our slogan our
motto is to provide energy for Life
safely and reliably delivering natural
gas and electricity in New England some
of you may know that Unitil also serves
in Maine and Massachusetts we serve
strictly natural gas in Maine in a small
footprint of both electric and natural
gas in Massachusetts but we are
primarily a New Hampshire company with
our headquarters in Hampton
uh here in New Hampshire we have about
390 employees
on our electric side we have about 78
100 New Hampshire Electric customers and
those customers are based in 34
communities in the capital or Concord
region as well as the Seacoast region
with our centralized electric Dispatch
Center in Exeter New Hampshire on the
natural gas side we have about 36 400
natural gas customers and those
customers are located in 22 communities
over in the Seacoast region only and our
centralized gas Dispatch Center is in
Portsmouth
uh in the map that you see in front of
you and displayed up on the screen the
yellow communities are the electric
community so you can see the Concord
region the Pinker red communities or the
gas communities and then the over the
the overlaid stripe communities are
communities in which we serve both
Natural Gas and Electric
now I'll pass it over to Cindy for some
ee conversation
all right thank you Kat
uh good afternoon everyone uh as Kat
said I'm Cindy Carroll and I'm
responsible for the planning and
implementation of Energy Efficiency
programs at Unitil thank you for the
opportunity to be here I've been asked
to give a brief overview of the Energy
Efficiency programs that are
administered by the utilities here in
New Hampshire and I thought I'd start
with just a quick uh refresher about
what Energy Efficiency is so that's what
this first slide is you may have heard
Energy Efficiency described as a least
cost resource or a first fuel the first
fuel we should use and those are really
accurate ways to describe Energy
Efficiency but put it really simply
Energy Efficiency is using less energy
to accomplish the same thing so we all
use energy every day we heat our homes
we cook our food we clean our clothes
and we use it to light our ways
very simply Energy Efficiency is doing
all of those things in a way that uses
less energy
a more efficient furnace more insulation
in the walls an energy star Appliance or
an LED light bulb these are all
efficiency measures well that will let
us do the things we want to do but use
less energy while we do them
but there is a cost to achieving those
efficiencies so energy efficiency
requires an investment but it is the
least cost resource
so for example in 2021 the average cost
of saving a kilowatt hour of electricity
with the Unitil programs or the utility
programs the average cost was 4.6 cents
per kilowatt hour
that's well below the cost of generating
and delivering that kilowatt hour to any
home or business in the state
the same is true for the natural gas
programs
the average cost of saving a therm of
natural gas in 2021 through the programs
was just 39 cents per firm of natural
gas
so the point here is that there is a
cost to Energy Efficiency and gaining
efficiencies
but it's a good investment it's a good
investment for the people who actually
install the measures and save energy
directly through a reduction in their
energy usage and ultimately their energy
bills
but it's also a good investment because
indirectly it benefits all customers
when we reduce demand for energy we put
downward pressure on Energy prices and
in the long run we may be able to avoid
having to invest in expanding energy
infrastructure to meet increasing
demands
so about the programs since 2002 the New
Hampshire utilities have partnered
together to design and deliver Statewide
Energy Efficiency programs to New
Hampshire customers
from 20 uh sorry from 2002 through 2021
these programs have saved billions of
kwh of kilowatt hours of electricity and
millions of therms of natural gas
they have saved New Hampshire customers
an estimated 3.9 billion dollars over
the period
and the programs are designed to serve
all customers across the state so all
residential customers and all business
customers big and small
we've branded the programs as New
Hampshire saves programs
the brand helps customers find the
program Services they need quickly by
having a Statewide single point of entry
into the programs for customers
now some customers know that they need
to call the utility or can call the
utility to get information about the
programs and Energy Efficiency in
general and they do that Unitil
customers call us directly all the time
and ask questions about the programs and
that's great that is a pathway into the
programs but for those customers who
don't have that understanding a common
way for us to market the programs Market
Energy Efficiency to customers and a
single point of entry for those
customers
really helps get more customers into the
programs by having this Statewide Brand
New Hampshire saves and behind that
stand all of the utilities in
Partnership
so I mentioned we have programs for all
customers and I'd like to give a little
more detail you know deep dive into what
those are
so starting with the residential
programs we have programs that offer
home energy assessments oh I'm on the
wrong slide so sorry
there we go
um that provide home energy assessments
that uncover opportunities for saving
energy in customers homes
we have Appliance and weatherization
programs programs that promote efficient
boilers and furnaces and heat pumps and
we offer no cost on Bill financing to
help cover the cost of the customers
portion of the job if that kind of uh
you know help is required of that
particular customer
we also partner with local cap agencies
these are Community Action agencies and
we provide services with in partnership
with the Caps to our income eligible
customers
now these services that we provide to
this group of customers are TurnKey and
what we mean by that is once they enter
into the program we take care of all of
the rest they don't have to really do
very much at all
and the services are comprehensive to
ensure that we get the biggest positive
impact that we can for these very you
know pretty vulnerable customers in this
in this certain sector
and those Services include health and
safety measures like improved
ventilation and moisture control because
we know that those kinds of things can
be really dangerous in homes
I also mentioned that we have programs
for our business customers both big and
small in addition we have programs
tailored for cities and towns both big
and small
so one of the most important things for
many small businesses and small
Municipal customers as well is the
assistance that we provide identifying
and completing efficiency projects
um as many as as many of you might know
running a small business can be really
time intensive can take a lot of time
for small business owners just to run
their own business and they don't have
the time or the expertise to evaluate
Energy savings or to find the right
contractors or vendors to complete the
work
the same can be said for small towns who
lack those resources to do those things
as well
so we make it easy we make it easy but
providing again TurnKey services to
small business and to Municipal
customers
um
that will provide assistance from
assessment all the way to the
installation of the measures and we're
using fully vetted and approved
contractors and vendors to ensure that
the savings are real and that the work
is done in the highest quality or to the
highest quality standards for these
customers
and finally we have programs for large
business and Industrial customers so no
doubt these customers have more
resources to vet Energy Efficiency
projects than smaller customers but they
also have many competing interests
there's always a competition for Capital
among these large businesses and what we
do is we help local on-site management
sell Energy Efficiency projects to their
often off-site Executives so that they
can improve their facilities here in New
Hampshire
helping them make the case that Energy
Efficiency projects at their facilities
will be worth the investment and will
improve the bottom line of those
operations
we find that when a business invests in
Energy Efficiency and saves on energy
cost more often than not those dollars
saved are reinvested in that facility
reinvested by expanding the business
there maybe adding a production line or
two or even adding additional employees
can certainly make the business more
viable in the markets they compete in
that's what I have it's a very high
level quick overview and I'm very happy
to take any questions you might have
thank you we appreciate that
presentation I have a couple of
questions myself actually sure
you stated at one point that Energy
Efficiency
Investments put a downward pressure on
prices
can you give us an indication of
how that happens and
how much downward pressure these
measures put on prices
other than just you know
common economic theory that says when
you you know supply and demand when you
reduce demand for a product or increase
supply for that matter you will have an
effect on price usually a downward
pressure on price so that's just common
economic theory but there's also a study
that's done in New England every three
years it's called the avoidance cost
study and I know some of you may have
heard of it but that study specifically
studies something called dripe and our
industry is you probably know loves
acronyms we use them all the time
everywhere but dripe is the re
demand
induced reduction price effect I think
I've got that right maybe not I'd have
to write it down to get it exactly right
but dripe is a function of what you're
exactly talking about we study how the
demand in energy the demand for energy
affects price and what that effect is I
don't have the number Quantified at the
top of my head but every three years the
New England utilities who operate Energy
Efficiency programs study that effect
and put a value to it
that we could get a presentation on this
stripe Factor at some point from the
utilities I'm sure we could give you
that presentation and also probably
arrange to have the consultant who
actually conducts that study who could
probably articulate how they do the
study much better than we could uh come
and present to if that's if that's
possible
sure that's great one other quick
question for you how much money do the
utilities make
on these New Hampshire saves programs in
program incentives
so there is a
performance incentive that the utilities
have the opportunity to earn there's a
threshold level of achievement that we
have to achieve before we start earning
the incentive the incentive is a
percentage of the
um
the program spending so how much it is
depends upon how much we spend on the
programs in any given period it's
typically a 12-month period and my
rough recollection is it's around four
percent of the program spending overall
but
um to get exact numbers for you I would
need to go back and and look that up and
get that number for you
okay great
other questions from the committee well
I see just about everybody has their
hands up on that side
well go this way representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question mine goes to we know
we heard about as I mentioned before
earlier about Christmas Eve and the
almost the ruling blackouts that we are
at risk of due to lack of power
generation I'm wondering uh and because
of that because it was due to weather
and weather Alone
um has there been a study I know there's
been a push for dealerships in New
Hampshire to carry more or to offer more
electric vehicles has there been a study
for the demand on the power grid to be
able to charge this increased amount of
electrical vehicles
so we have a regular uh planning cycle
for distribution planning for our
infrastructure planning so it wouldn't
um
involve generation capacity so we would
only be planning for the demand electric
vehicles or other distributed energy
resources might put on our system but we
have Incorporated
um der or distributed energy resources
of which electric vehicles may be won
into our regular distribution planning
modeling
so we're projecting an adoption rate for
electric vehicles and then planning how
much of that would happen on our system
and then you know some of this is
locational right so it depends upon
where it happens first but um that very
complex distribution system planning
does include accounting for electric
vehicle adoption
representative Kaplan is next
thank you Mr chair um and thank you for
your presentation I want to go back to
the costs and benefits of the New
Hampshire saves program and
um we've had calculations of a four to
one benefit based on the investment to
economic benefits overall in the state
but I'm going to talk a little bit about
the or ask you a little bit about the
social benefits as measured in demand
for these programs and
What proportion of these projects per
year would you say are met through your
budget and what What proportion of the
projects fail to be accomplished because
there's not enough money in the pot so
to speak
it is a little bit program specific so
for some programs we have enough money
in the budget in in any 12-month period
to meet all of the demand for that
program
um but then there are also other
programs where uh demand for program
Services exceeds the budget in any given
year so you know one of the important
things about the programs is continuity
so people will make commitments to
projects late in one year
hoping that there will be projects or
programs available the following year
for them to participate in so that's why
program continuity is important so that
people have confidence that there will
be a program next year they'll invest
the time and effort they need to get a
project together and hopefully that'll
get funded in the following year but the
short answer to your question is it is a
little bit program specific but there
certainly are programs where uh and and
year to year specific as well sometimes
there's more demand in one year than
another but there are times when there's
more demand for program Services than we
can satisfy in any one period
representative barishni is next thank
you chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh building on representative
Summers question about electric vehicles
the utility
how much can the utility do in terms of
capacity and Supply uh to deal with it
or what what do you do to compensate for
what you know is going to happen as a
utility as opposed to capacity
um if I understand the question you're
asking how so we do this modeling and we
project load profiles and then what do
we do in response yeah that's I am not
an engineer okay Engineers are are very
good at knowing what they need to do in
different parts of the system so again
it's very locational it's not ubiquitous
some parts of the system have are very
robust have a lot of capacity and can
take on a lot of extra load other parts
of the system not so much so it's it's
really a system-wide planning effort and
the the remedies that you're talking
about to be able to take on that
additional capacity that we're
projecting are also very locational in
nature so a remedy in one spot might be
a very different remedy in another
let's hold the questions to one per
person because we have another utility
that wants to present and we're going to
have abundant opportunities to talk
about Energy Efficiency in the next
couple of months representative munz is
next thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for coming in I have a question that I
was going to ask the folks from
eversource and you as well
what percentage of your customers have
Smart Meters installed
we have an Ami system deployed across
our entire system so it's a system that
we installed in
15 2015
and its power line carrier so the signal
is actually carried back to Hubs through
the power lines and then communicated
from there but all of our customers in
New Hampshire on the electric electric
customers have Ami meters
Mr chairman
yes we're going to hold it to one
question per person so everybody can
have a chance here could I ask
eversource to just answer that question
too yeah offline okay thank you uh
representative Corman had his hand up
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I'm imagining a
scenario where one of my constituents
says I want to make my home more energy
efficient I want to weatherize it I want
to put in a heat pump something like
that does New Hampshire saves uh direct
them to somebody who can actually do the
work I mean are there qualified
contractors through the program
yes there's a couple of Pathways in the
program so if you already have a
relationship with a contractor you
already know somebody you trust and want
to do business with they can participate
in the programs
assuming that they meet a certain level
of qualifications
um but we have TurnKey Services as well
so if you call us and you say just
interested in having my home assessed to
see if there are any energy you know
savings opportunities we will send out
qualified contractor to do that
assessment you'll get a report that says
what all of your opportunities are and
how much they might cost and what the
incentives might be from the utility to
actually take those steps and then if
you want we can actually assign a
contractor to that project as well so we
have onboard qualified vetted
contractors who are subject to Quality
Control measures uh and and the same
qualifications that your own contractor
would be required to meet thank you
representative lewicki thank you Mr
chairman and thank you can you give us
some typical payback times for energy
efficient appliances or whatever I know
you know for instance refrigerator is
running full time so that you know there
should be some projection of how long it
would take to pay off a more efficient
refrigerator and obviously we hear about
LED bulbs and it really depends on usage
which is variable
I don't have those specific payback
periods I would just offer that that
varies very much depending upon the type
of equipment you mentioned a
refrigerator there's a whole host of
refrigerators that meet the energy star
standard and would qualify but each one
of those probably has a little bit of a
different usage profile depending upon
how many bells and whistles you want to
have on your refrigerator you know do
you have an ice maker or do you not
those kinds of things and then also how
do you use it you know do you use you
know do you have a big family where you
know kids are opening the doors and it's
open all the time or is it just you and
you and the wife and you don't open it
that much so it really does vary I'm
sure there are averages but I I don't
have those numbers with me
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um if you referred earlier to the um
the drip study I'm going to try that
acronym again demand reduction induced
price effect thank you uh presumably the
economists that the utilities
collectively hire to conduct The Ripe
study every three years are very smart
and they specialize in the utility space
if they have concluded that
the average cost of saving a kilowatt
hour is
4.6 cents even if they were wrong by 50
and the number was more like seven cents
isn't that still substantially less than
the price that we're all paying now for
a kilowatt hour of supply
yes it's fair to say
thanks
okay let's move on we have another
utility that would like to present um
yeah I just want to briefly hit on my
contact information at the end of the
presentation I know that there's a lot
of familiar faces here but some new
faces as well
um poor representative muns has been
getting inundated with emails from me
but many of you will know that you know
during storms like Mr locata stated you
know I'll be sending those of you who
represent Unitil service territories
frequent emails you can reach out to me
about emergency events about pieces of
legislation constituent concerns
anything like that but we just want to
make sure that you know you know that
we're here and I think I speak for all
of the utilities we're all here as a
resource for all of you and whenever
something comes up Reach Out
thank you very much
and next up I believe is Liberty
Utilities
good afternoon
please turn on the microphone please
thank you yes thank you okay thanks
again uh chairman Vos and uh and the
committee for uh hosting this event
um I'm going to try not to repeat uh
everything that my colleagues have said
uh but I would like to commend uh both
uh unitel and eversource for their
presentations uh the undergee efficiency
presentation and we are a partner in
that process so there is really nothing
more for me to add and I would like to
just reflect that my friend and
colleague Mr Foley did a very nice job
in terms of describing the electrical
system the system in Liberty is very
very similar just a little bit smaller
and we'll talk about that in a few
minutes
um
my intention this afternoon is just to
introduce Liberty uh to the committee
but also introduce myself as you've
probably gathered my accent is
um a little bit south of Manchester
about 30 miles south of Manchester in
the UK I joined the gas company in 1979
as a an apprentice on the back of a gas
truck at that point the uh the um the
gas business was government owned as was
the electric business and both the gas
business and the electric transmission
business in the UK were privatized
during the Thatcher Reagan years the gas
business became lattice the electric
business became National Grid who you've
probably heard of and in early 2001 2002
National Grid acquired lattice to form
the company that you've probably heard
of now and have been mentioned today I
worked for National Grid and and its
prior companies until
2021 for about 42 years and then joined
Liberty here in New Hampshire almost two
years ago I came to the US in 2003 I was
the head of operations for Wales in the
southwest which was about a fifth of the
UK came to the U.S for two years which
turned into three which turned into
seven which is now turned into 20. I
became a very proud American on the 4th
of July 2017 and I became a Granite
State for about about two years ago so
if anybody asks about my accent I
usually say I have an original New
England accent
I didn't think there'd be questions this
early but I'm happy to take them
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um and your
name is Neil proudman
okay I guess that covered it continue
please thank you
so um
so a little bit about Liberty
um Liberty is a growing company and as
you can see from the slide here every
one of those dots represents a part of
the territory we're way up in the north
as you can see in the Northeast in in
New Hampshire uh but we have territory
across the US also territory in Chile
and also territory in Bermuda in fact
during a recent storm there were Crews
from Salem New Hampshire actually went
over to Bermuda to support their
restoration so we are a growth company I
think a lot of folks think of us as a
very local company that's because one of
the things we pride ourselves in is a
very local footprint but as the American
Gas Association describes as now we are
a mid-sized American combo that's the
the category that we fall into
um in terms of our regulated utility
groups of which Liberty New Hampshire
apart we are 34 distribution utilities
uh in New Hampshire we are the uh only
utility in uh in in the Eastern region
I'll talk about the little the Eastern
region in a few minutes which has both
electric and gas we're in 13 states one
Canadian province that's in New
Brunswick part of the same cluster in
myself and I've already mentioned the
two International utilities about 6.8
billion in assets and just over a
million utility connections
the east region which we are part of
encompasses New Brunswick ourselves here
in New Hampshire Massachusetts Upstate
New York which is the Old Saint Lawrence
Gas right on the Canadian border and of
course now also North American water on
Long Island and we also have some small
territory in Georgia and our
Massachusetts territory is in Fall River
of all of the Eastern region businesses
New Hampshire is the largest so where
the performance of New Hampshire goes so
does the performance of Eastern region
so we're a big part of the puzzle for
for Liberty and an important part of the
puzzle here in the in the Northeast
just getting a bit closer to home now
this is our territory in total we have
just short of 143 a thousand customers
97 000 of those are gas and 45
000 are electric uh we are one of the
smaller Electric utilities in New
Hampshire but as we as as we like to say
we enjoy a big seat at the table and we
do pack a punch when we need to
um which is evidenced by the two storms
over the holidays we serve 45 towns a
total of just over 9 000 square miles
and matrixed employees what I mean by
matrixed employees is I you know I'm
responsible for the bottom line and the
performance of all of New Hampshire but
some of the um some of the employees
that support New Hampshire also support
other regions too so the direct number
of operational employees dedicated
solely to New Hampshire is 176 6 and we
are supported by the remainder of the
430 who again their output is I am
responsible for so so the single throat
to choke for Liberty in New Hampshire is
is in fact me as you can see from the
slide
um the blue the electric
um
our electric business is non-contiguous
you can see better on this slide Monroe
Lebanon Charlestown and Salem uh in the
event of a storm when we're trying to be
efficient and we're trying to use our
resources as best we can it's a bit of a
jaunt from Lebanon to Salem but we do
watch the weather very carefully and we
are able to Stage uh stage our employees
in the best possible
um best possible areas however however
as you can see from there it's not not
being contiguous some of that is is
quite difficult
um 45 000 customers as I mentioned
substations uh Mr Foley mentioned uh
substations 14 feeders 39 and then
operational employees who are Crews and
supervisors uh 56. a couple of uh
highlights of our system Rockingham
substation was a 10-year investment we
unveiled it last year it is uh to
respond to significant growth in the
Salem area and
um and and actually uh we've got a an
inquiry that we're working on now which
is enabled by that investment which
could potentially bring an additional
400 jobs to the area and then storm
Elliott and Diaz in the over the last 10
years as Mr Foley mentioned there are
damages and those damages result in
multiple outages
um over the last 10 years the maximum
the maximum outage number for any given
storm was somewhere in the region of
64.65 storm Elliott and Diaz were 110
and 107 respectively so they were
significant events for us and one of the
things I would like to say is when we do
get these events we do all work together
across the utility aisle and I do want
to stress that myself and my colleagues
here not only do we participate in
mutual Aid
um but but we're also communicating
through the event to make sure that we
are all serving all of New Hampshire
customers together
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for being here
um I'll ask you the same question I
asked the folks from Unitil how many of
your customers or what percentage of
your customers have Smart Meters
installed I I don't have the answers to
that okay times but we can get it for
you great thank you
okay
let me uh just get my uh get my place
back so so so our electric business as
as you can see here it's non-contiguous
it is spread out
um and and yeah I was mentioning how we
work together a good example is through
mutual Aid uh once we'd finished our
restoration we were able to send some of
our contractor employees to uh to unitel
to support them and then also send some
of our own employees up to up to the
co-op so we do all work together for the
betterment of all of New Hampshire
customers
representative Wendy Thomas has a quick
question yes thank you Mr chair
um it just seems um rather inefficient
to have these these spaces so far apart
um how was that decided and is there any
way to make them contiguous at some
point
um the only way you can make them
contiguous is by acquisition
um if you look at the energy Network
across all of the Northeast there's lots
of pockets of how these companies have
evolved over the years this was the
Granite State Electric business behind
that would have been some other
iteration so this is an evolution so the
way to fill in the gaps is either I
acquire some of my colleagues here or
they acquire me
thank you that's probably the most
straightforward answer
if we think about the gas system so so
you know I've been uh you know I I have
worked in the electric space for a while
for National Grid I headed up there uh
construction business for a while I know
uh Mr Foley talked about trees and the
importance of trees in 2006
um snow came early to the City of
Buffalo a lot of Buffalo was backyard
construction a lot of that backyard
construction the customers out there had
kind of tried to hide the wires with a
lot of trees and everything else and in
October 2006 those trees all came down
and that entire backyard system was
lying crackling in people's backyards so
trees are the main issue but but yeah I
was part of that business for a short
period of time but most of my career
I've spent in the gas industry I'm a
member of the institution of gas
engineers and managers which is a world
of wagon organization
um
outside the U.S which also gives me and
others their professional license to
operate here in the US I'm a member of
the American Gas Association managing
committee and also I'm the executive
sponsor of the best practices Steering
group across all the industry when I
think about expletives in a gas
engineering an engineering office the
biggest expletive is single feed
wherever possible you try and design a
system so that there are multiple feeds
into a system you don't want to rely on
one single pipe feeding a system what we
have here in New Hampshire is a single
feed feeding New Hampshire which starts
in Texas and finishes in Concord that's
the Kinder Morgan line we are
susceptible to volatility in that line
either price volatility through the
folks that feed into that or Supply
volatility by the very nature that we
are on the end of the system and like my
colleagues have described both on the
electric and the gas side price
volatility is subject to changes and
influences that happen outside our New
Hampshire borders and the question that
you asked earlier was how can we
insulate ourselves from both of those
both of the supply and price volatility
and I'd like to finish with that in a
few minutes but our system 97
000 customers it is the biggest gas
Network here in New Hampshire
120 operational employees who on any
given day you will see on the streets of
Concord
um
1400 miles of Maine 70 000 Services
um Mr Foley mentioned uh substations the
gas equivalent is a regulator station
the word for that in the UK is a
governor station and I will flip between
regulator and Governor because of uh
because of just uh the way I was brought
up uh critical valves these are valves
that we use to isolate the system in the
event of an emergency we have 477 and
then cities and towns are 32. at the
most um if you look across the nation
the biggest program of Works Across the
Nation is what we would say is the leak
prone pipe process this is a process
that eliminates a 10 inch and below a
pipe which is susceptible to leakage and
they fall into two main categories the
one is cast iron and the other one is
best deal best deal a steel that is not
cathodically protected cathode is a
basically a um a a a a it's it's an
element that draws all of the um
all of the rust and the Badness from the
pipe to the cathode so this is for cast
iron and bear steel the best deal rusts
and cast iron depending on how it was
laid
um if you have a stress point on a cast
iron Mane you then have a perfect
circumferential crack and when you have
a circumferential crack they leak
instantly and and and and there is a
very very quick release of gas
fortunately cast iron systems are low
pressure so you're not susceptible to
large amounts of gas but they do leak
and in Winter
um and and this year is extraordinary
but during the the I just trying to
think what it was called the Cyclone
that hit the Northeast a few years ago
the biggest issue that I had when I was
in a prior role in Boston was broken
Mains through ground movement above that
permafrost and instead of the leak going
up it went across and all those
basements in the old buildings in in
Boston we finished that year without
incident but therein lies the risk so
that is why we spend a lot of our
efforts replacing these pipes not only
do broken Mains and leakage and and some
of those cast iron pipes as well leak
out of their joints but but joint
leakage is only a small amount but also
unburnt natural gas unburnt methane in
any form including Dairy is uh has an
impact on the environment so a few years
ago I would have said that my job was
the safe efficient and um
and compliant operations of our
distribution system I now add on to that
um
environmentally responsible
so so just looking at the system
um
one of the ways we do try and insulate
our customers from that price volatility
is by basically shopping around we have
a number of options we have pipeline gas
we also have
um
um liquefied natural gas which we can
truck around to our locations and we
have storage capacity and then our final
line of defense which we have in places
like Manchester is is propane air
um
I guess uh we're going to interrupt you
here for a question uh representative
lewicki uh thank you Mr chairman
um I have a question you know the um
when Lawrence got burned down there was
no real local pop-off valve on that they
had a control Loop that was thousands of
miles long are we susceptible to that
same type of outage or do we have pop
you know simple pop-up health or
something similar to that in New
Hampshire
so uh so um I was um
I was involved in that the restoration
after that incident and I can confirm
that the situation and the cause of that
situation in Lawrence we are not
susceptible to that in New Hampshire
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question which is if not cast
iron or bare steel what are the good
resilient pipeline components so so
coated steel still is still a a firm
favorite of the transmission system
local system is is plastic pipe it is
um it is flexible when handled correctly
it is strong it's robust in fact when
fused together correctly the fusion is
the point of fusion is the strongest
point in the system when it's done
incorrectly then it is a risk and uh and
and there have been some incidents
Harlem in New York was one such incident
where a fusion failed but when done
correctly it is the most uh there it is
the it is the strongest part of the main
in the same way as trees are to the
Electric System mechanical excavators
are to the gas system which is why we
spend so much money on damage prevention
and educating anybody who who is is
digging up the road anywhere near our
infrastructure
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um actually to piggyback up on that last
question uh in Merrimack recently we had
a significant gas leak because of a wall
that collapsed at the outlet mall
and I was going to make the comparison
that rocks are to gas as trees are to
electricity we're the granite state do
you spend time and energy Shoring up
rocks so so most of our time is uh you
know there are areas where we will have
to put pipe through rocks and and we pay
a premium at that they actually call it
ledge I I was out on that job at the
Merrimack Premier Outlets and uh what
was interesting to me was how normally
the rocks that impact our system are the
ones that are underground that we have
to work through that they're not what is
a basically a human-made rock face uh
which which which interestingly enough
had signs and barriers on it saying
danger Falling Rocks
um which then came down on top of our
main the good news was and I actually
have have pictures if you'd like to have
a look afterwards
um we have uh X we have a above ground
meter installations and the rockfall
felt literally a foot short so the
actual damage was to the underground
infrastructure and not the above ground
emphasis structure and and our crews
moved very very quickly to isolate the
area and have now
kind of rerouted uh the the main in
order to be able to get the Premier
Outlets back on
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh quick question
for you here I see from what you've said
here and posted it looks like that you
are not solely relate relied up on
imported gas coming in from West Indies
and have you been asked is that true and
have you been asked for uh energy
Generation by other energy suppliers to
provide natural gas for the Generation
Um we haven't no no and uh and yeah I
would we
the gas that we use we either we take
from the Kinder Morgan pipeline that
comes from Texas
okay so if in the interest of time if I
can draw your attention to Keen
uh so so at the interview nobody
mentioned keen and uh and uh it's become
a bit a little bit of a little bit of a
joke around around Liberty because one
of the things that is interesting about
Keen is Keen is not fed on Pipeline gas
Keane is the only remaining 24 7 propane
air system in the entire nation Catalina
Island off California
um was was what was the other one that's
been closed down now so this is this is
unique
um the other thing that's unique about
it is I actually think engineering
students should go through this plant it
is an Antiquated plant we've spent a few
hundred thousand dollars over the last
couple of years since I've been at
Liberty and and there is a coincidence
um
improving the switch gear and improving
the technology which operates that plant
however however over the next few years
we have a decision to make and when I
think about the decision that we have to
make what we're trying to do is think a
little bit differently think a little
bit differently as how we can serve we
can serve Keen it's served right now
with a combination of propane air the
specific gravity of propane air is
different to national natural gas where
natural gas leaks it goes up when
propane air leaks it settles into the
ground and it permeates into the ground
so as a gas engineer my preference is if
you're going to have an emergency as
something that goes up instead of
something that goes down so we're
looking at some opportunities for Keen
um mayor George out in Keene has
released a document which is a green
Keen document we've got some ideas that
we're working with
um with mayor George and and also we've
presented to the energy committee out
there and what we believe that we can do
is transition
from a propane air mix potentially
to a hundred percent hydrogen within the
next uh five to ten years hydrogen is an
emerging fuel in the gas space it is an
environmentally uh sustainable fuel
um
it can be produced with uh with green
electricity produced from our own New
Hampshire water and our own New
Hampshire uh sunshine and our own New
Hampshire winds so it has some
opportunities there and across the world
gas companies are looking to decarbonize
their networks by other sources than
simply handing their networks and their
customers over to an electric business
because we're not there yet so so
hydrogen is a possibility there's uh
there's a pilot in in the UK at the
moment where 668 customers are being fed
a 20 hydrogen blend with no detrimental
effect on what you would say was the
normal
low pressure distribution infrastructure
we're in a slightly different place in
the US at SoCal or taking a look at this
as are others and it's now a regular
conversation point at the American Gas
Association but I really just put that
slide on because we may end up just
staying at renewable natural gas we may
end up somewhere along that transition
but the opportunity is there by thinking
a little less traditionally and a little
differently
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um that was the question that I was
going to lead in on as I'm looking at
this step ladder that says 100 renewable
natural gas can you explain what that
means because I thought
uh 100 renewable would mean that it's
like zero emissions is that yeah so so
the the so RNG we can get RNG from a
number of places the Rudolph the plant
it's um I know I've pronounced that
wrong in in Bethlehem uh is uh is
converting our own New Hampshire waste
into a renewable natural gas which could
be put into a pipeline system either by
Trucking it in and feeding it in we're
uh we've actually got an RNG
um a bid document out right now looking
at some prices to see if that is
feasible as an option to put into our
system and good for our customers uh so
so yeah there's there's a whole host of
opportunities so Dairy is another way
that we can create RNG and again put
that into the system and burn it
follow up thank you
um so I understand RNG is what we're
going to call it but I guess what I want
to understand is about the net effects
in terms of emissions
so so my understanding is that the net
effects are negligible when compared
with unburned methane
and I'm I'm an engineer I'm not an
environmentalist but but my
understanding is is that this is this
these are the options that we need to
explore rather than just
um you know utilities particularly Gas
Utilities
um avoiding the question
so so so this is an opportunity I just
sorry can I can I continue
representative Wendy Thomas I guess has
a question thank you Mr chair
um I'm a little concerned about
um this transition which is in 10 years
which is fairly aggressive the the
propane equipment can't handle natural
gas so they'd have to replace the
equipment to handle the natural gas the
natural gas equipment can't handle the
hydrogen so they'd have to replace that
it seems like this is a heavy hit for
the community to get to hydrogen so
there are 1250 customers out in Keene
right now
um can you repeat that there are 12
around 1250 customers out in Keene right
now a blend of RNG or or hydrogen up to
20 would not require any changes in
appliances or or the burner tips in
particular anything over that would
require a visit and would require a
conversion but this industry did this in
the 60s this industry converted from
locally manufactured towns gas to
natural gas around through the same
process so so the model is already there
on how this industry can transform
itself in a different way
okay so so thinking
just just thinking about the future
um
just down the road there's a there's a
gas holder and that gas holder in in in
the 1800s was was state of the art
when I think about the gas industry and
the
challenges facing the gas industry
um We're Not Gonna We're Not Gonna face
those challenges by barreling our heads
in in the sound neither are we going to
address those challenges by pulling
together The Usual Suspects and with all
due respect when I and I think about the
north The Usual Suspects around a table
it's the you know the the regulatory
staff within the utilities plus the
lawyers plus the legislature
I actually think in order to address the
issues we need to think a bit broader
than that
that old gas holder down the road is is
maybe our our Back to the Future
opportunity because when I look at that
gas holder what I see is locally
um locally sourced locally produced
locally stored
um energy
and and when I think about
insulating New Hampshire from the
volatility of what happens outside our
borders we have to consider a modicum of
energy Independence in the mix and that
gas holder reminds me of a time when
there was such energy Independence we
have good New Hampshire wind we have
good New Hampshire Sunshine we've had a
little bit of that today we've got our
own Dairy we've got our own dump a good
example of which is in uh in Bethlehem
we have heat and mothers out front
working with utilities in Boston around
geothermal we have rocks up here as it
was pointed out we have Woody biomass we
have plenty of Woody biomass and we also
have the opportunity to um to create our
own hydrogen but but here here is the
thing and this is one of the one of the
things that I would like to leave you
with
we need to get the unusual suspects
around the table we need to get the
scientists the innovators
the business Community the college
principles the environmentalists we need
to bring the community together across
the utility aisle across the political
aisle in order to
pull our resources
to figure out what the energy future
looks like for New Hampshire
um
I'm looking forward to being a part of
that that was one of the reasons I came
here for the opportunity to engage in
those conversations but again just as a
reminder the key challenge is right now
for me
is a little bit of regulatory
uncertainty my colleagues mentioned
Energy Efficiency there was a docket
that came out a report that came out on
Friday afternoon of last week talking
about Energy Efficiency which we had no
idea was coming I've mentioned Supply
volatility and what we're trying to do
to offset that I've mentioned price risk
volatility and the other area which was
mentioned today is an aging Workforce if
you will notice I did actually spell
aging the UK way and not the US way
so with that I'll leave with an apology
and thank you very much for listening
well seeing no questions I thank you
very much for being here excellent
presentation
and all three of the utility the
regulated utilities did an excellent job
nice overview from all of you we have
one more utility to hear from
and that's uh the unregulated but
extremely important New Hampshire
Electric Co-op
they're especially important to me
because I am a New Hampshire Electric
Co-op member
so we welcome the two of you to uh
to our committee room and uh looking
forward to hear from hearing from you
thank you chairman Vos and honorable
members of the committee my name is
Alyssa Clemson Roberts and I am the new
CEO at New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative uh sitting to my right is
Michael Jennings our director of
engineering I have only been in New
Hampshire and at the co-op for four
months so he's here to keep me out of
trouble today
but at New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative is a little bit different
um the people that we serve are member
owners so we don't just have customers
we have members and owners that help us
make our decisions they elect a board of
directors that governs what we do uh
they help approve our budget set our
rates and our strategic planning
we do operate at cost and over the last
two years we've returned eight million
dollars in margins to our members
we also have a subsidiary called New
Hampshire broadband and we are currently
providing Broadband to about a thousand
of our members in six communities now
foreign
so we were founded in 1939 I'm sure many
of you know that Rural Electric
cooperatives began because no one wanted
to serve the territory we serve
I liken it to our Venture into Broadband
today much of our members are left
without adequate reliable and high-speed
internet service which is why the
Cooperative once again said we would
answer the call to serve we serve about
86 000 homes and businesses in 118 New
Hampshire communities we own and
maintain about 6 000 miles of line and
we operate in nine of New Hampshire's 10
counties we have 250 employees that work
in 10 different locations and about 40
percent of our membership is seasonal we
do think that is shifting a little bit
uh post pandemic as people are finding
New Hampshire a great place to live
I think one of the things that really
makes us different is that we operate at
a non-profit basis so again when we
return money to our members that member
stays in the state that money stays in
the state of New Hampshire
and uh if you didn't know in 2000 our
members voted to Grant authority to our
board of directors so we were no longer
regulated in the state and we also have
the lowest power supply rate amongst the
four utilities at 13.8 cents is where
we're headed we still think it's too
high but we're headed in the right
direction
um I think one of the things again that
make us special is that we're
accountable to our members and that's
again why we founded our Broadband
business so while I'm at the end of the
day I will be short and sweet and answer
any questions you may have
thank you that was a short and sweet
presentation
but the question on everybody's mind is
how did you achieve that lowest power
supply rate among all the four New
Hampshire utilities discounting of
course the other three utilities need
for profits
uh what are you doing differently that
allows the co-op to keep rates lower for
every for all their members
so I will say there are a number of
things that we do differently first of
all we're not regulated so that allows
us to actively Monitor and procure our
power supply in a different way we don't
buy our power twice a year we purchase
our power when we find the market to be
advantageous to us so we may purchase
every month we may purchase in a
six-month block we may purchase you know
thirty percent sixty percent ninety
percent all depending on what the
markets are telling us is happening
right now and what is going to happen in
addition to that we have long-term
mid-range as well as short-term
contracts that we do currently I would
say we're more
um in the short-term business of power
procurement but if we see prices
continue to decrease we'll start looking
at options to hedge for the future
the biggest difference is we're
deregulated so we're allowed to do
things a little bit differently
we think it provides us with an
advantage
would you say a little bit more about
the short-term versus long-term versus
midterm procurement that you do sure any
time that you buy power it it's a little
bit of a guessing game except for what
you're doing right now
so when I go out to procure power I'm
looking at the market and I say where do
I think it's going and what's about to
happen and so if we think that there are
indicators or if our experts are telling
us the price of power is going to
increase over the next six months we'll
start doing a six month or maybe even a
12-month procurement and we'll try to
buy out to beat the price that's coming
if we think the prices are going to be
lower what we'll do is we'll wait and
we'll procure in 30-day increments or a
two-month increment to go ahead and
watch that price fall what we consider
to be long term would be over 10 years a
midterm would be anywhere from about
three to ten and short term would be
under three
so what kind of factors do you take in
con into consideration
as you look at the market and try to
decide or predict where prices will go
sure so I can tell you right now we get
we have a number of experts that provide
us with forward pricing their best
guesstimates is what I like to call them
on what natural gas is going to do that
market has been relatively volatile I
would say since the beginning of covid
or the February storm after covet
started and then you add in factors like
what's going on in Europe we know that
there's a war that is impacting the
price of natural gas and I would also
say that the continuing rise of using
natural gas as a heating element is
putting a Competitive Edge on natural
gas and who gets this product and who
doesn't so natural gas is one of the
huge indicators in New England and
across many of the markets we've seen
markets and their construct be built
towards more natural gas but there are a
lot of concerns that come with that you
know hedging that way or or basing a
market construct on a resource that we
know number one we don't have the
pipelines to transfer and number two we
don't have the storage capabilities to
hold which puts all of us at risk when
natural gas takes large swings
excellent representative Christian has a
question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
um so that question sort of leads me
into if
um sorry what what would you say is like
the mix of
um your energy sources compared to the
other utilities that operate in New
Hampshire in terms of Reliance on
natural gas versus other
sources
well I I would say in the New England
area we're all relying upon the New
England ISO or at least we are primarily
in New Hampshire
um if you look at other markets you know
if you look at the ercot market they
have a lot of Reliance on wind as well
as natural gas if you look at the spp
market they have a fair amount of wind
as well as coal if you look at miso
you'll see a lot of coal as well the
Rocky Mountain West which doesn't have a
market has a lot of natural gas coal
they're seeing an incredible amount of
wind in that area and solar and the
California ISO is Shifting towards a
fully renewable base so it really is is
regional dependent but we're all
dependent on what the New England ISO is
doing
you know with the generation situation
representative Nutter has a question
thank you this is actually from one of
your customers they asked me to ask this
question how do you calculate net me
during month to month
you use the microphone please thank you
it's a little bit complicated because of
um what type of net metering we offer a
bunch of different rates for them we
could follow up with us with the member
individually if that would be easier
follow up follow up
also if you could put that in writing
and a contrast
um contrast that to how all of the puc
regulated utilities calculate their net
metering if you can get me that in a
printout yeah absolutely I'd be happy to
follow up with that thank you and then I
had one more
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um by now you probably know what my
question is uh the answer is 100 thank
you
question was that it that wasn't sure
the question was the percentage of
customers with with uh smart readers or
so okay representative Summers has a
question
just a quick question thank you Mr
chairman quick question for just for
verification
um due to your rates being about 50 of
what the regulated uh providers are
um is that 50 difference from what I
understand from what you said due to
regulation profit and then because you
can go to the market more than twice a
year
um the cost of average for hedging
um I would say yes with the caveat that
you know I'm not involved in how the
investor on utilities procure their
power so I would strongly recommend you
have a conversation with them about you
know what they do with that I think one
of the things the co-op does because
we're allowed to is we assume some risk
with the market prices and and I don't
think that's what's going on with your
investor owned utilities but I would
just caution to say that you know we at
New Hampshire Electric Cooperative try
to balance a risk and a cost and so what
we've been doing is is either purchasing
smaller amounts when we see the market
go down or larger or larger amounts when
the market goes down in smaller amounts
when it goes up
representative Thomas Doug Thomas has a
question
thank you Mr
well since this question has been asked
so often uh my question is could you
define what is meant by a smart meter
because I think there's some confusion
or could be confusion it's that term is
used very Loosely yeah it is used very
Loosely I would say there's a couple
different categories you could look into
with Smart Meters one is just a
automated meter rating which is a system
that you would use to go around and
gather the data from meters more easily
there's also an Ami system which is what
we currently own it allows
bi-directional communication so we get
data from our meters actively throughout
different periods throughout the day but
we can also send data out to the meters
as well so it's a two-way communication
for example if a member called us and
they wanted to change rate or they
wanted to change something that's
programmed within the meter we could do
that over the system as opposed to
having to visit their house there's a
lot of value in the different data you
get from that type of smart meter system
follow-up
um so uh are any of the smart meters
that are used in this state capable of
determining
what energy is being used at what time
of day for what Appliance
not down to the Appliance level you can
see at the household level and then
there's also a sub meter and Technology
you could use for the appliance level
certain appliances or load types have a
curve you could determine just by
looking at the data but at a high level
the meter will give you pretty much the
household usage as a whole thank you
I have a follow-up metering question
if I have an electric car at home and I
want to keep track of exactly how much
electricity I'm spending to charge my
electric car can I get a separate meter
for my EV charging station yeah so a lot
of utilities will offer a separate EV
charging rate in addition to a lot of
the car chargers themselves actually
track the usage on that similar to solar
or battery the inverters with those
track the usage so a lot of times
utilities will deploy a sub meter but
there's also other ways you could use
meter and Technology within the existing
equipment to leverage that information
okay thank you representative Reynolds
has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um going back to your earlier comments
about the volatility of natural gas and
how it drives the price of electricity
and the vulnerability and all that
um what to what extent is the co-op
looking to the price certainty of
renewable resources
um
to help balance that and before you
answer I just want to mention
one of my favorite projects in a prior
position was the one megawatt solar
installation at the North Conway water
Precinct
and they decided to procure that system
and part of the reason they did that was
because the net metering rate was a very
I would call it reasonable and fair
value for any electricity they would put
back onto the system in the Mount
Washington Valley
so I would say that we are supportive of
you know small renewable projects in our
area for sure I think as we enter into
strategic planning in the summer
probably early fall we'll be having some
of these very discussions and right now
we're in the process of working with the
national renewable cooperative and
talking to them about you know
implementing some battery storage
throughout our territory as well so I
would say anything and everything is on
the table our goal is really to provide
you know affordable reliable energy to
our members and they overwhelmingly tell
us that that is what their priority is
representative Nutter has a question
thank you this is from another customer
um wants to know if um you if you or you
and all the utilities if anybody gives
to the education tax credit scholarship
program
I'm sorry I don't know the answer to
that but I can follow up I know that New
Hampshire Electric Cooperative does have
a number of scholarship programs that we
have ourselves that we run but I don't I
don't know the answer to that and I'll
have to follow up
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair I'm
intrigued by these smart meters and that
you you say that 100 of your customers
have them do you credit them as one of
the reasons for your prices being so low
no so I would say it gives us more data
to use from an engineering standpoint on
planning perspective it really helps us
prepare our system for the future so
when we look at things like hey is our
system going to be ready for electric
vehicles or what percentage of our
membership is starting to adopt electric
vehicles it helps provide data for that
but it it doesn't give us too much extra
data to help us prepare for power
procurement uh it just gives us more
real-time accurate modeling information
representative McGee has a question yep
I'll follow up on where you left off and
just ask I know there's a lot of
discussion now and a couple of bills in
the Senate regarding transactive energy
and I'm assuming that one of the
benefits of having infrastructure that
includes
smart meters is that you can support uh
the Future Energy market in terms of
being able to support Peaks and such is
is that is that an accurate way of
looking at it yeah correct it gives us a
lot more flexibility with what we can do
at the end user point at the member
point because we have that additional
visibility and more real-time data it
allows us to do more things as far as
transactive energy or time of use rates
and how we Implement those yeah and I
would just follow up that we are in the
process of rolling out a transactive
energy rate and have been doing a pilot
project with Plymouth State University
on vehicle to grid projects so I would
say that that's something that we're
looking forward to rolling out for some
further testing and further member use
probably q1 or Q2 of this year may I
follow
follow up
um so transactive rate can you just tell
us what you mean
yeah essentially something that uh
signals what the market is doing at the
time so essentially we have to buy the
power from somewhere uh and so whether
it's ISO New England or own membership
we would prefer to to do it in a way
that helps facilitate it for our members
the best so the idea behind the
transactive rate is that you know we
could provide two-way charging and get
our supply from you know either the iso
or whatever PPA or membership is willing
to provide the energy to us at the time
that we need it
representative barasni has a question
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question can you talk about
the price difference between a smart
meter and a regular meter and also how
did you finance and roll out the how did
you make the decision to uh
yeah so I guess there's a pretty large
range there I mean there are smart
meters that have live high technology
even built into them which we're not
procuring those those could be in the
multiple hundreds of dollar range
whereas you know your traditional analog
meters are actually getting even
difficult to procure nowadays so there
is quite a wide range what I'd say that
the typical meter for a utility is
probably in the hundred uh 150 range
nowadays and as far as you know how we
went about procuring them we actually
participated in a grant about uh 10
years or so ago Grant process which
helped share some of the costs for our
membership and rolling out the smart
meters
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee I want to thank the two of
you for being here
and uh like to thank all the utilities
for being here and before I let you all
go I just want to offer the committee
committee one more chance to ask a
question of a member of any of the four
utilities represented here today so
Christopher representative munz gets the
first shot
so eversource guess what
uh just like to know what the percentage
of smart meters that you have are so uh
eversource uh we have AMR meters which
are not quite as smart as Ami meters but
we were able to eliminate
um you know having the the meter readers
go door to door to read those so we can
can do the drive-bys and collect the
information that way so uh Ami just use
the you know broader terms is usually
more described as a smart meter as Mr
Jennings described AMR would not be
described as a smart meter
follow-up follow-up any idea on the
percentages so you have is zero okay am
I yep okay correct thank you
representative has a question for
someone uh thank you chairman my
question is uh for Unitil
um about the on Bill financing is Unitil
the only
um utility that offers on Bill financing
and can you talk a little bit about that
like what things can you finance and uh
do you have to have your credit approved
or what's the process
so each utility is a little different
but my understanding is that all of the
utilities are offering on Bill financing
and we don't have a credit check for
customers but they do have to be in good
standing in terms of their in terms of
their payment practices with us so
that's the hurdle but I think some of
the other companies May impose a credit
check before they do on Bill financing
for their customers so it's a Statewide
program but there are a little bit of
differences from company to company but
generally it's the same on Bill no fees
no interest and
parameters for actually qualifying for
the loan might be a little different
between the companies but for you until
I can say we don't do its credit check
we simply require customers to be in you
know in good payment practices with us
follow-up representative brezny so what
kinds of projects like if you install a
bunch of solar panels at a house and
then if the person moves and somebody
else moves in do they pick do they now
is the the cost of those panels now
included on the new owners bill or what
what's the the process there so we don't
uh actually
solar panels are not part of the pro of
the programs right so it's Just Energy
Efficiency measures so probably a better
example would be if you add insulation
to your home so we come out we do an
assessment you don't there are
opportunities to add insulation in your
attic or your walls and that's going to
cost a certain amount of money we would
give you an incentive to take that step
and do it but you would also have a
co-payment for that project that
co-payment for that insulation could be
financed on your bill over a period of
time
and it I'm sorry the rest of your
question was does it follow the customer
if you sell your home you would have to
your final electric bill when you leave
that home would include the balance of
that loan so it does not transfer to the
next customer who owns that has that
account or that meter
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um actually this is just a request if we
could get the contact information for
the last two presenters sent to us thank
you
additional questions of the utilities
this won't be your last chance because
they'll all be back to testify on
various bills before us but if you have
any other general questions
representative bereshny I would just
offer if any other utility has a program
that they want to talk about with the on
Bill financing that
not sure you have the right
people in the room from the other
utilities and I apologize I don't have
all the specifics in terms of their
programs
okay looks like we're done here and I
want to thank you again all the
representatives of the utilities for
being here today giving us a
presentation
now I will remind the members of the
committee that we will be returning to
this room on Thursday this coming
Thursday at 10 30 for a presentation by
ISO New England followed by another
presentation by the New England power
generators Association
then on Monday January 23rd we will
assemble here at 9 00 a.m for a
presentation by our Public Utilities
Commission this is a rescheduled
presentation from
last Monday or whenever it was that they
had to cancel
that
day will include that presentation from
9 to 11.
and then starting at one o'clock in the
afternoon we'll do some committee
business between 11 and 11 30 then we'll
go to lunch and then in the afternoon
we'll start our first bill hearings
for this session
I think we uh I've forgotten exactly but
I think we have four bills or five bills
on the schedule four bills Maybe
and then Tuesday January 24th in the
morning at nine o'clock from nine to
nine thirty we'll have a presentation by
the community power Coalition of New
Hampshire
and that will be followed by
four or five more Bill hearings
probably four and there is at the moment
a
executive sessions scheduled for that
afternoon
the reason we're going to start having
executive sessions that early is because
there's two reasons one we have five
early bills that have to be disposed of
by February 16th
and the second reason is we want to get
builds into the hopper so that they can
get to the house floor in a timely
manner
we don't want to have what happened last
session happen this session
those of you who were here last session
will remember that several times we got
to the house floor and we had so many
stne bills on the calendar that we ended
up having to table several bills we
couldn't have a floor debate on those
bills because we just ran out of time
and the speaker requested uh that I
table those bills I don't want to have
to go through that again I want floor
debates on all our bills
and the only way we can make sure that
that happens is to get them to the floor
in a more timely manner so we're going
to be executing executing bills
sooner rather than later and with with
the idea being that we'll get them to
the floor so that we can have time to
debate them all
yes representative McGee yes thanks I'd
just like to ask if we know which bills
we're going to be hearing so we can get
a jump on them
when will we have the list
it'll be published in the calendar
nothing beforehand on Thursday
okay thanks I've had to make some
changes to the list I have the list but
I have had to make some changes because
I just found out this morning that one
of the bills that we got that I didn't
think was an early bill is in fact an
early bill so I've got to make some
changes
any other questions from the committee
seeing none I thank you all for your
participation today and I'm going to
close this session of the stne for today
thank you